[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
i think that you make him do it twice
huh i love that you're into making them
listen to it two times in a row i know
it's a weird
it's like how i get myself ready to go
how do you prepare to do the podcast
what's your ritual
i come in i have a seat i look you
directly on the eye and i go thank you
and then i'm ready to start
what is gratitude yeah yeah um and the
little
tear just comes out of your cheeks it's
black from mascara no it's just a no
it's just one blood it's just a stigmata
yeah just one one trickle of blood comes
down
and then i know i'm i'm filled with the
holy spirit ready to go so you guys we
haven't um been in here what the podcast
studio is starting to come we've totally
refurbished the podcast studio i didn't
even recognize it when i came in
there's a bigger door where a smaller
door was there's shelves where
what was that before that was a
children's closet that was the place i'd
go cry and now it's the place i go cry
and put on makeup
yeah and there's books in there no one
can see we're talking about but it's
beautiful we're gonna be so
organized now we've got a new cubby
we've got the wallpaper you guys chose
for
us that we have emily in the corner with
emily in the corner tiny little desk
we don't let her sit at big girl chairs
just to keep her
i'm a baby you go down
if i have an ego i love that if you look
that young you got to sit at the kid's
table
thank you fran um so lindsey sterling is
on the episode today
lindsey sterling is like honestly like
part of the reason i was so scared to be
on youtube
people that do these incredible things
violinist songwriter
dancer started youtube in 2007. she's
been out there
via linen for years it it
i like when i saw people like lindsey
sterling that had 12 million followers
and is like flying from trees
i can't play a kazoo i can play
the symbols i bought a flute because of
american pie
did you buy a pie no i just bought the
flute got it i went scraped down the top
and not
the recorder you know what i went
scraped out the top of my mouth with a
record
i was rocking in a rocking chair playing
a recorder and bam rocked back too far
and dug out the top of my mouth
i walked up to my mom and dad showed
them the clip of allison hanging and
going one time at band camp i stuck a
flute in my pussy and i said i don't
like a flute
i forgot that was the and my grandma
bought it for me never knew how to play
it but i was like
allison hannigan had a flute i need a
flute could you understand that's the
kind of fan i am i am a good fan
i'm a great fan i love that people go up
to allison hanging in airports like i
bought a flu because of you
she's like cool i love her she's like a
loser
you guys just so you know emily's uh now
that you guys are gonna know emily
she does injure herself in ways that are
so hard to believe and i just want you
to know she's not
exaggerating it took me years to believe
her when she says
things like this i have a band-aid on my
head right now
the two of you together is dangerous
emily we did a show this weekend in
irvine
an outdoor car show and emily
fell so hard that sorry you're not
laughing i'm sorry no no i'm laughing
emily fell we were we had waited um the
whole show to come up on stage give away
merch
emily was walking backwards she was so
excited she was
walking backwards looking at me being
like i want you to get a picture of me
if i can post it so my ex-boyfriend gets
jealous
and then she went to turn and when she
did her foot caught
the the black wire that runs the tv from
the microphones
and she fell so hard held her margarita
up in one hand
held the phone up in the other hand and
just beamed her little head off the side
of the parking garage floor and then the
sound guy was like the whole building
the sound guy ran up and went
you fell hard the whole building shook
oh shit
i'm sorry emily said he's dead to me
so then how did she look up at you when
she fell oh she looked at me like
in pure terror and shot like a child
like
it was just i was laughing so hard i
couldn't do anything i couldn't help at
all
emily and i just look over to emily's
hair it look like your hair was like all
frizzy
and i couldn't breathe i was laughing so
hard
i have a giant goose egg on my head wait
let's see no it's we're audio only
you take that oh shit well he's filming
can you take the bananas
no it's just like put a picture on there
the bruise is much better but it's just
like a
slit that is stigmata that's actual
that's the thorns right there
the third eye i see oh my god that is so
funny no
sorry it's not funny you're okay there's
something it was we you guys
man came up after the show and he said
the show was funny but watching you fall
is a funny issue
you guys oh it's bobby lee yeah you guys
we called bobby lee like i thought he
had minutes ago when we needed him and
now he's calling back when we don't need
him
you need some explanation about
something about woody allen or something
um
uh no but you guys used to hang out
together all the time right and just
share the same thing i'm kidding yeah at
a party
right right how old are you
all right anyway so you're plotting now
yeah we were going to call you about
something else and then
it happened uh and then you called back
i love you
something asian related no it was about
secrets
i love you tell you later bye um okay so
we are gonna move on to lindsey sterling
we have so much to say we're gonna do
big open next week but lindsay i know
you guys
love her her fans i mean i've my goal is
to have fans that
say things in the comments to me like
the ones that say to her
um she's so beloved music saved my life
yeah maybe how do you know i'm not
working on a little ditty
i don't know we know everything about
you i know i'm not working on a backup
plan have you looked at my
uh my trash emails have you looked at my
do you mean emails or drafts
have you looked at my traps
um okay so lindsay she's amazing i did
talk a lot during this one you guys i
was so excited to meet her sometimes i'm
like a little kid at santa where i'm
just like
and i'm working on it and i promise i'm
this is the last episode
that i really interrupt right now what
about the kids that meet santa and cry
you ever thought about that i did that i
was crying because you were interrupting
somebody i was
interested i wasn't here i was i was so
excited to talk to her
and um it was exciting
it's just i was so excited to talk at
her i was just so excited
to answer all the questions i had for
her because here's what let me just tell
you guys really i know i've already said
this
i definitely i believe that when you ask
them a question i've been on so many
podcasts in my whole like
i sometimes need a second to think
personally so i think
i am projecting onto the people that
they need a second to think
so this when i'm on a podcast someone
will be like so tell me about uh your
worst date ever
and in my head i'm like can i have a
second to think about this so
i go let me tell you about mine to give
them a second to think just being a good
host
but they don't think they don't no one
knows the motive behind doing it
yeah so i'll be like what's your most
embarrassing sex story then i go mine's
this
so then they they're percolating i'm
worried you're gonna burn your hand on
this candle or they can
stop me uh what if i just uh when you
didn't burn it off i'm a witch yeah
exactly
i think that was your eyes just turned
black perfect sense
um i love you guys so i'm gonna stop
explaining why i interrupt i'm just
gonna stop doing it and you guys are
going to have to find something else
wait we can't answer this about me oh
it's not sad at all i just want you guys
to know i'm working we're we're all
working on it i love you
i'm an interrupter too look yeah what
emily
i'm a beauty queen first of all emily
and i have gone so full grey gardens at
this point
i'm big edie and i'm we were like eating
there's a lady and she just goes come on
little lady
so um i love you guys ben tonight and
tour dates holy shit okay
we are going on tour we really wanted we
were like we're done we're done by the
way we planned this open for last two
hours and we forgot everything we wanted
okay tour dates they're on the website
you guys
um what's the website
whitneycummings.edu
um it's dot com uh uh spokane april 15
to 17th we are coming it's happening
half capacity
indoors we just did this in salt lake
city it was great it was so fun
you can't make it we're gonna be back
it's safe
you can watch uh we did a live for salt
lake city you can see on whitney's
instagram page
at the end we did a video we did a
surprise and for the people that
couldn't come to the show we're gonna be
doing lives during the show
at the end so if you like you know can't
come because you live with your
grandmother and she hasn't been
whatever you get it if you live with
your grandma in a house made of candy
hansel and gretel
breast ca braya california where is brea
brea is it the inland that's like every
girl i went to high school with that's
what they named their kids that's so
funny bria bryce and briley
bryn brandon but spelled like
b-r-y-n-n-e it's b-r-y-e-n-n-y-s
three crosses on the right side of the
road child abuse uh
braya california it's basically la it's
like an hour outside la brea california
may 7th and 8th all new material houston
texas we're coming at you
may 13th through 15th but very politely
we're coming very popular we're coming
at you we know
we know you texans don't like l.a
weirdos coming in but i'm half from
texas
i spent my entire childhood in texas
yeah i love it where
my aunt she lived in uh dallas houston
austin and san antonio
every summer a different place then she
moved to chicago and i lived there for a
long time
i lost my return i went there for a long
time you lost your virginity in texas
yeah the guy called me on purpose yeah
my ex-boyfriend
wait what wait what i lost my virginity
in dallas
at my college boyfriend's house he
called me by his ex-girlfriend's name
first thrust you lost your virginia at a
whitney cummings show and you can get
tickets at whitneycummings.com right now
in texas nobody did any comings at this
event
what was his ex-girlfriend's name claire
he goes claire i love him
to be fair you do look like a claire
i'm so yeah i'm too bad you weren't
clairvoyant didn't see that coming
beach um can't beat it we can't beat it
so anyways you guys should buy tickets
lose your virginity did you learn that
on the word of the day
clairvoyance no i learned it from
charmed damn thanks for listening
i'm still trying to make a play for the
word of the day nobody wants it back
if you want the word of the day back
stop go somewhere else unsubscribe
no don't subscribe tempe arizona four
through six we're kind of san antonio
we're coming to you
uh except um uh tickets are not on sale
yet they will be on sale soon any other
also if you guys are listening to this
the contest to win a zoom call
on this podcast with the team ends march
15th so all you have to do is you have
to go to store.whitneycomings.com and if
you buy any merch
it counts as one um like
try one like an entry entry one entry
thank you
one entry there's a reason they usually
read this on the screen one to the inch
yeah ours just says no signal
one entry into the contest you just go
to good for you your screen literally
just says no
you go to the good for you instagram
page you show us your receipt
we'll tally up how many items you bought
we'll put your name in a little drawing
and you can win a zoom call
on this podcast with the whole team
we're really wanting to involve you guys
more in the podcast now that we have
things plugged in and stuff we're really
just it's been a year and we're really
gonna
start doing what other podcasts do we're
going to get there one day
we're going to take calls or take
questions i feel like for the oh sorry
for the only podcast you're crying or
laughing no i can't stop laughing
thinking about emily falling i'm sorry
oh it was so funny i told my mom she
didn't think it was funny i'm sorry when
i say when someone falls i
like i like there's been three or four
times that i've seen a fall that the
person was okay but
it like brings up like repressed emotion
from old emote like i
might have his handicap he fell all the
time he falls constantly
one time he fell down a hill and rolled
for like 20 minutes and the hill was so
small
i was like how are you still rolling
down this hill you fell 20 minutes ago
and you were in the barn with the
groundhogs me and my mom are laughing
so hard one time my dad one time
one time my dad lit a firework for me
when i was little because i couldn't
light them obviously and then he
couldn't get away from it fast enough
and
like when he went up his pant leg it
went up
it was so funny yeah god bless him he
was such a good dad he is a good dad
he's still alive he's alive
i'm sorry just when i i'm just sorry
it's like oh fuck
it's just like have you ever seen that
um uh
he felt so much have you seen the kelsey
grammer video where he falls
oh god i i was laughing you ever seen
beyonce fought on those stairs
uh uh yes that i did not never missed a
baby not laughing
she never missed a beat i do not laugh i
brace for impact
and imminent suicide that was amazing
yeah so she fell down all those stairs
and got immediately up look up um look
up
you guys if you just need a laugh uh
having a bad day
look up kelsey grammer fall i left
i had to like go i had to like leave
work and come back i was laughing so
hard
and then this one is just okay i saw and
i saw a man and his wife fought on the
escalators of belk one time from the top
to the bottom one time when i was an
informal model
uh got it uh my coat caught in the
escalator fell back
oh i saw in salt lake city this weekend
i thought remember that i fell from the
front of the stage to the back of the
stage getting up there
nobody even helped me i don't think i
saw that well i was like don't touch
button
in the cover times well here's the thing
in covent times if you fall no one tries
to help you up
it's so true it's wild so true you fall
and everyone's like
uh this summer a kid fell in front of me
and i stepped over it and i'm normally
very good over it
i stopped because i couldn't touch it to
be like are you okay
and i did i fell on a bike i told the
story on the brian kellen episode but we
had to pull it don't tell it again
uh i fell off a bike like in the middle
of my neighborhood and like no one would
help me up like i was truly bleeding and
i was like are you okay i was like
no and i don't and i like put a mask on
and they were like
no one would help me out people are just
going to start dying of open wounds on
the street
when i see people fall out i like to go
excuse me what's your pronoun
and then when they tell me oh can
someone help them and then i will leave
because i don't really involved you know
it's too much drama but you don't want
any microphones
you can't help people now is so much
like how do you identify
someone else handle it and you said help
them i've done my part
he needs it i think that's a nice thing
to do
i saw a woman fall in target recently
fainted
um and uh i was with tim dillon she
fainted and i went to help her and no
one
wanted me to my help how did you help
excuse me i see a non-binary human just
fell into i picked her up and i threw
over my shoulder
i felt like i know that's not where i
feel around
like i started someone's like why is
that lady carrying dog food around i
started taking selfies with her and
being like i'm a hero look
um put her back down
got it um love you guys tmz
we um uh love you any other
announcements uh
uh lindsey sterling is coming up it's
emotional it's hilarious
it's she's she's she i feel very
grateful she's a violin of a human
she's yes but she also said she opened
up about a lot of things in the podcast
that she's not opened up
publicly i feel very grateful and
special that she has a song in her heart
and she really let her the one line she
got to say
she opened up it was music to our ears
she had two things what she did get to
say
you've never heard on any podcast before
ever she said i think that is true
she said my uh that's fine but i'm an
addict
but i'm a co-dependent but identify as
an addict
lindsay sir we said lindsay and she said
yes and we said what's your trauma
by the way this is how we know we need
to stop with that shit because
a drama executive uh emailed me from the
business was like i love your podcast
want to develop a drama i was like wait
i think i talked about it so coming this
summer to lifetime i don't think i talk
about like
addiction too much on this podcast um we
love you
like subscribe follow us uh benton ray
subscribe
follow share comment leave a review tell
your parents about it call your
grandparents tell them
on instagram for psychology don't cast
no do yes follow a good for your page on
instagram yeah and also
we are going to start releasing audio
and video simultaneously
on a day that is yet to be determined oh
not when
this next week we're going to start
we're going to start next week because a
lot of people are having confusion about
the audio's out where's the video
we're going on the same day it's going
to be
it's going to be wednesday next week but
don't hold us to anything you know what
i mean but it is gonna be tomorrow
i think it's gonna be the moment oh no
we love you guys
oh no that's as good as ours it's out
now but listen
really though before you're literally
listening to him
but before we go though actually listen
this is important
guys we have a lot of content in
different places that we're starting to
create so you do need to follow on all
the different locations
such as youtube or special youtube
videos now just for youtube
this is my very serious voice and then
also you want to make sure that you're
following the good for your page
there's going to be a lot of after shows
things happening and you want to be
there for that you don't want to miss
out on it
lindsey sterling choreographs dances for
four months but we
are going to do things like just eat on
camera for two hours we'll do mukbangs
when you guys write these beautiful
messages like why aren't you guys you
know in the marvel movies it's because
you're not subscribing and liking and
commenting
well i'm not in because they didn't ask
me i'd like to retire so
just whatever you need to do to get me
there like our future rests in new york
you guys
emily we need to pay for medical bills
please i need a fab fit
fun deal she's going to break her neck
everybody fix my little eye
you need a fab fit fun deal that is such
a deep cut i love you guys
uh also can we get fabfitfun as a
sponsor i want to open some fun ribbons
and
i'll tell you all in boxing by the way
we i will not stop i'm going to say this
right now i will not stop doing this
podcast
until someone makes you gets a fab fit
fun
paid partnership just because i want to
see her open this box
wait i want a partnership what's mine no
you are were you you're here already
at the fab feb boxes use code whitney
okay guys
love you lindsay sterling don't write
out story elephants
or butterflies yay i'm just so
fascinated by you because
your like spirit and your energy and
your
playing the violin i just want to really
quick just figure just figure out i'm
sure you've talked about this a million
times like
what why the violin like did you see
something when you were a kid like how
does that occur to you because i
it would never occur to me to want to
play the violin it looks so scary and
daunting
and like i'm like i i was a kid in music
class it was like can i get the triangle
can i get the what are these symbols
i was this person i was the symbol
person in
music i remember the recorder i was just
about to bring up did you try the
recorder
that was the music education we got in
my school like everyone got a recorder
like the only instrument that no one
uses past
high school which is a pity
think about how much better music would
be if recorders were in
songs it's like instead of a guitar solo
and bust out your recorder mid concert
but i do think like like this is
important because
you have to um learn
this early you know i just think that
the violin is such a awkward position to
play i don't know it's just very
uncomfortable and so i think it is an
instrument that is really really
best and you found a way to make it even
more uncomfortable
i did amazingly surprisingly
not for us but so i do think it is like
important to learn as a kid not to say
you can't learn later
but um i kind of gravitated the violin
because my parents both loved classical
music
and not like they were shoving it down
my throat but that's what you heard
it's just what was in our home it's what
was playing and i remember like
listening to the sahara zod and my dad
told us that it was a story about a
princess
who you know and i was just like oh my
gosh tell me more and so for me music
was
that sounds great but that is also
something they put in a movie to show
that someone's a psychopath but
in your case not what happened not the
case
thankfully it didn't turn into a
psychopath story
they'll just cut to the guy like playing
a violin just to like add weird
dimension to his character
because it's something that is so hard
to do that it like makes you go like oh
yeah that guy's just
has a different brain than me right yes
he's something must be off which
some people might think about myself as
well something must be
not if you're on a show with me you're
not the one that people think
something's off with because
you're a safe space oh good anything
goes but yeah so i just
gravitated towards it and when i was
like five years old i started begging my
parents to play
so that's kind of where it all began
when were you like
like because that because that's just
when i it makes me feel better to hear
that like when i hear about like
great golf players and athletes it's
like they started number five and i'm
like oh
as if that's why i'm not a celebrated
famous violinist
like oh yeah yeah if i had just been
able to start earlier like that's
i realize again something that we use to
make ourselves feel better about other
people's astronomical talent
um but did you know that um
albert einstein played the uh
violin yes i did damn
fuck you know there's like not a ton of
like amazing are you trying to imply
that you know more about
violinists than me well to be fair i
kind of forgotten i hadn't thought about
what i
hadn't thought about that in a while but
you're like that's the first thing you
learn and then you move on
you reminded me thank you i'm glad i
have now remember that
because it is like do you have things in
your br like i always just people to do
impressions people that play instruments
like this i'm just like
are they left brain are they right brain
sometimes they like just see the world
in a different way like are there other
things that you do
where you're like oh only violinists do
this or think this way or
i know it with comedians comedians right
you can walk in it could be the
best moment they're winning the lottery
their mom's cancer was just cured and
they'll find a negative
joke to say or there's a reason this
isn't as good you know what i mean
there's always like until the checkpoint
like we all
we have this habit where we just go to
the negative no matter how positive
yeah the like if um my dude uh
gave me a gift for valentine's day oh
and brought flowers and i just was like
what did you do
what did you do like what are you making
up for like my brain just like goes
there and i was like oh that's why i
should be a comedian you know or this is
the right fit like is there anything
like i'm just curious like
you must be very mindful and meticulous
yes you know i feel like sometimes my
personality
doesn't exactly fit the personality of
what
like the kind of the classical musician
and i think that's why i ended up
steering
that's why you had to make your own
genre yes because
classical music is very much like um
i don't know i felt finally i discovered
that i wasn't someone who wanted to just
regurgitate what other people
had already had already made you know
and just
i remember being in lessons and
orchestras and you had to dictate
how you expressed every note and like
this one swells and
you know it didn't feel like i got to be
like making a lot of creative choices
like your personality
so it was about it's about sort of like
falling in line
if you're playing in an orchestra that's
kind of how i felt about it and
i worked for a while until it really did
it and i was like wait why don't i like
this anymore like it's not even
that i don't love it it's like i don't
even like this and i used to so it's
like
and it's just because for me the
progression naturally would have been
like learn to play and then learn to
create with it
and it stopped at learn to play and then
just get better and better at playing
and you know and it recame alive for me
when i was like
oh i need to be creative with this i'm a
little creative soul
and so that's when it was like i
re-found my passion i got re-excited
about it and it's
you know kept me excited to this day
when you can do it on see that's
something that's really like
just so important because i think
there's so many people right now who i
see
are achieving their quote goals or the
goals they made for themselves
and then they're they're not happy and
they have to realize like oh
i made this goal before i really knew
what the job was
yeah do you know what i mean like i made
this goal also when
the only um opportunity to achieve my
goal was this one
way like before i knew there were even
other options you know i mean
so sometimes it's like i have to re-uh
um
envision or uh my goals and it's okay to
get really good at something and achieve
your goal and be like
but this isn't actually making me happy
yes and i
and this is what will oh my god it's
doing it on my terms
that's what i left out of my dr my my
vision board or whatever the fuck it was
when you were manifesting it like
because i remember
when i got like a tv show and i was like
this was my dream
and then it was like the wrong team and
i was like ah shit i didn't say like i
want to do it with the right team of
people like
me like you're so focused on being in
your dream that you're not like but i
can also change the dream around because
it's just not
i needed to be on my terms absolutely
now it's a perfect way to say it because
i think you can only make a goal that's
as advanced
as like the next step you know like you
can see like you don't understand until
you've worked with a team like that was
a perfect example
you don't know how important that is and
so like just being able to constantly
not like give up on your goal once
you're like well this isn't
what i expected you know so done with
that you know
it's like okay evaluate and sometimes
it's just tiny tweaks that you need to
change in order to make
what you're doing feel great and other
times it's like massive changes
but yeah that's just so i think that's
just such an important
skill to have and then also to know
as like when you're creeping towards
your goal
knowing that you are even if it doesn't
look like what it looks like so
um like i was working on something this
past week and there was like this pa
who was like i was talking to him and he
was just like yeah and i'm just like not
doing what i want i want to be producing
or i want to be doing whatever and i was
like no no
you're that's happening this is just act
two
you're not doing what you want right now
but this is like you're about to
right you're so close you know what i
mean like sometimes we don't know when
we're
in we think we're in a mistake or we're
in a
um uh like a life uh derailing or a
it's just like oh no no you're just like
very close
yes and this is exactly when you would
doubt yourself but in this part of the
movie
the person wouldn't give up and then
they would get what all they want so
just do what you see in the movie think
like the person in the movie
right well i recently read a book called
think and grow rich
and i loved it because i mean do you
need some cash are you
tight on cash um i've seen the views uh
check's not clear right yeah no it was
actually
such a cool book someone kept telling me
i should read it it's basically about
like manifesting
and about achieving goals and i don't
think it has the wrong title because
it's not just all about money it can be
applied to like any goal or
dream you have it's about thinking it
and then making it happen
and one of like one of the chapters he
just kept talking about how so often we
get right up to the point of where we're
about to succeed
and that is when most people quit
because that's when the
challenges get real it gets it gets
harder and
if it doesn't work out for me i still
get to say well i didn't try
yeah do i mean i still get to have the
um i get to
let myself be off the hook by deluding
myself into saying like well i gave up
so
yeah well or like i tried i tried it it
didn't work
and but it's like oh so many people quit
when they're like literally right there
on the brink you know maybe
and i know i got to that point several
times in different chapters where i was
like i like literally don't think i can
do this anymore but that's when you have
to just like
put it into that extra gear and keep
going forward because you could be
so close to your breaking point in a
good way it's so
so true and you don't really know until
it's over sometimes
you know but that you're just making me
think because your trajectory
uh in your fame and your career like
it's it's
been so yours
and that i just feel like is so amazing
and rare and i'm so jealous
but like so happy that there are
creators that can do what they
like actually let because my guess is
when someone was like hey
uh you know do you want to do a thing
and you're like yeah can i hang
from a ceiling and spin in circles by
playing the violin or that might not
have been super early
oh that was supe that was actually super
recent right so but i heard on your
thing that
people would say but like do you need a
singer do you need this and you're like
just let me post this and i'll show you
that i don't need any of the shit you
think i need
yeah well you know at the time so you're
referring to like back in the day when i
was on america's got talent
and you know i think that was my point
of like
i almost gave up after that and i could
have very much said
i really tried i really gave it a go
because i had like
been performing at open mic nights i'd
been you know traveling in my little car
trying to do gigs here and there i you
know
i've been working really hard then i end
up on america's got talent i think oh my
gosh
this is it all that hard work is paying
off and
then i'm on stage in front of i mean i
think it was 11 million people and i
just get
totally cut down to size and like
humiliated
and you know is that how you felt oh
absolutely i mean if anyone wants to
watch it it's
it's tangibly like don't watch anything
uh you can watch it it's fine
but let me i'm over it now let me can i
and i and i'm sorry i haven't
um oh sorry okay so if i interrupt
someone when they're talking emily
shoots me with a dart gun oh
so i just get so excited and i truly
think the only reason she has to donate
is she's so worried about hitting you
uh i love that do your viewers know that
uh they know yeah they're the ones
[Laughter]
i just want to watch one where you know
you actually don't worry oh i will
i'm trying so hard to not interrupt you
it's working is the good news i just i
want to get back to
what you were just saying like how were
you feeling oh cut down to size that
before we
interrupted yes i mean but let me just
ask you a question you literally just
interrupted the interrupting of asking
not to be interrupted it's actually it's
actually a skill i'm allowed to
interrupt you
i'm not allowed to interview her oh
shut up oh you don't have a thing
bullets in it
say women can't use guns i know we all
know it all this time
um no just that
like just and i don't know if this is
helpful to anyone i think it's more like
you know i've just been in those shows
and been a judge on the i feel like so
much of it is
produced i feel like they do that
because they're like okay we have to
pick this person
and so we have to someone has to say
something negative or someone has to say
something
you know what i mean to make a show
that's why i've never wanted to do those
as a judge because i'm like i know
they're going to go
we for we have to you have to say no to
this person i'm going to be like
i can't i like you know what i mean like
it's
right i don't know i just feel like a
lot of it's fucking they overdo it for
fake drama and you're like you know this
is someone's life that you're
right doing this to and like people
vulnerably performing that's that's
drama enough
i know and these are people that already
like the fact that you got here
already means like you're the like
that's how i feel like all these should
go
right you're here which already means
you're in the top .02 percent i'm just
making up math but you can't con
correct me so i might as well be right
like you're already in the top .02
percent of fucking performance
you've won but we have to pick someone
and because of whatever fucking debt
we're last year we went with this guy so
we're gonna go with this
person and that's just say it like that
right no one is watching that show i
realize i'm pitching a terrible idea for
a terrible show that no one's gonna
watch
but i just like that always bums me out
because i even feel like the viewers are
like
okay you're just saying that because you
have to like say something to make drama
here's the good news yes do you really
think
you would be the most famous person in
the world
on youtube had that not happened to you
well that is actually
why i like this story so much is because
like
at the time it was the most devastating
thing that could have ever
happened to me and i was like humiliated
like i cried backstage
for an hour until they told me like
we're closing up for the night like you
gotta go like i mean i sobbed i felt
like my dreams were over
blah blah i was very young and you know
really that's by the way if that
if someone did that to me now i would
also think you know what i mean it's not
about being young this happens at every
age and exactly shit
fine no but that's a really good point
it's not like oh i was naive and young
it's like anybody
who faces a huge disappointment of
something that you're excited about
totally healthy reaction
it's normal healthy validation dude
you're not
crazy i think it's like you work your
whole life for something and then you
have that's right in front of you and
then
yeah someone that knows how hard this is
has the gall to say something like it's
just like get the fuck out of here like
those shows like they make so many
amazing careers and those the chills
moments are amazing but those like
unnecessary negative moments that they
i just am like i think you're i think
that
hollywood people assume that
viewers are as sadistic as they are
that's a really good point
yeah no because i've never seen a viewer
like i love that part of the end where
she
tore her apart like no you're like that
was unnecessary but look
he wants my tickets comfortable you know
it's uncomfortable to watch people go
through that
and you know but i look back on that
experience and
it was my moment of like i don't think i
can do this anymore like this is too
hard it hurts too much and i'm too
embarrassed
there's that like inside voice and that
like gut that intuition that
spirituality whatever like
you want to call it yeah just kept being
like you're not done yet like
get back on that stage it's not over for
you and
thankfully i did the fact that someone
that fucking
sorry i deserve that one continue
but i'm just saying that that i just
feel like right now like i just in
general and this is part of the reason
you are who you are
that i just think we all have to be
gentle and great and have grace with
ourselves because
the kind of person that was going to be
devastated
by that is the kind of person who's
going to
fucking put all her heart into videos
and become famous later so i'm saying
i'm just saying someone that cares that
much
that's a good quality like i think we're
just in this
um trend right now of pathologizing good
qualities
where people like i just care too much
i'm just too nice and you're like
no i'd like to stay that yes like
and i'll say it all the time like when a
predator comes out or something i'm like
i guess i'm just stupid and naive and
i'm like you know what
i'd rather be that yeah i'd rather care
too much and be the one
crying because i care so much you know
than the other way around it's going all
right fuck this
you know right that makes that like i
just feel like the way you react to
something like that
everyone should be proud of if that's
the way you act because you care so much
and that means you're gonna excel in the
next chapter
absolutely and like that's that thing
that even now i remind myself of when
i'm like
too discouraged and i feel like i care
too much i'm too disappointed to move
i'm like
actually no like i've been through this
before and i've persevered through hard
things before
and i can do this you care the exact
right amount
yeah and you know looking back like you
said you were like would you
be as successful now if i had won the
show and hands down no and it took
i actually think it'd be worse i'm sorry
your manager's here because you'd be the
winner of fucking america's downtown and
that's all anyone would see you as well
you'd ever be seen also they have
dude you had it you got the perfect
sorry you got the perfect
situation well and you know it's funny
how sometimes
talking about goals again like what you
see like all i could see in that moment
was
i want to win this show so badly i want
to win america's got talent it'll change
everything and
it turned out to be the best thing for
me to not win because one it made me
stronger it made me get up after falling
i think you would but also like i had
already signed a contract that basically
said if i win the show you own me and
you own everything i do for the next
umpteen years
and if i had one that would have gone
into effect i wouldn't have been able to
start my youtube channel like literally
i never
so much like the voice like i'm sorry do
i have a gun
no fuck much like the voice
that was getting dangerous i realized it
was heavy when it was flying to the air
i'm so sorry i thought it was like a
bobby pin holder this is
a that's like 10 pounds this is a nice
brand mascara and i'm keeping it it's
concealer then i'm keeping it packed now
we do have the same exact skin tone it's
a mistake
um much like the winners of the voice
like i can't name one winner of agt
yeah do you know what i'm saying right
you win what obscurity
like i think it's better that you win
weren't you in amer uh
uh american idol didn't you win it but
like good
yeah you but this is like dude you're
this is you're so famous
my dude knows you like literally i've
the we've had some pretty big people in
this podcast oh my god she's fucking
amazing he's seen all your videos oh
he's all he climbs rock climbs and they
all watch your videos together like it's
you're very big in the rock climbing
community wait let me a bunch of guys
that are strong and rock climb watch my
videos
you yes okay you don't they're their
fingers are all fucked up
oh they have like weirdly dry callous
fingers that have cuts on them
and so if that's a standard for you yeah
and here's what's crazy
smooth hands is at the top of my list
they they also can't get them wet
because it softens them
so they never wow so he's really into
this
yes okay it's not just like a hobby like
a once a month thing
no this is because you have to hang from
these
things on the ceiling to keep your
fingers strong that's just just imagine
him just like hanging out when you come
home and he's like
you know why i feel like they're jealous
because you have such strong fingers i
bet
i do do you have the most strong fingers
will you give me a little
thumb a little warm a little finger work
your work
like i feel don't break her fingers oh
my god so are your fingers insured
i think i i do have some sort of this is
when you're
the most successful person in your field
when you're not sure if you have
insurance i like looked over on your
body
i'm like i think i do she does right on
her hands she had insurance for the hair
hanging so i would
you had insurance for hanging from the
bun video yes
we had to in order to film it like a
live experience so the insurance person
comes in and is like this
feels like you're not gonna make it so
uh we're pulling out of the deal yeah we
are we're gonna come to the show
because this is gonna be very
entertaining um because you might not
make it
uh but uh but so they they had a you had
trouble like insuring that set
i think that was in order to ensure the
set we just had to pull an extra
insurance for my hair
so as you're hanging from the bun like
did you were you like i know this is
gonna work
okay so uh so for anyone who's probably
really
confused like why we're talking about me
hanging my hair
no everyone listening knows you oh
you're very famous
that's very generous it's just a metrics
thing like i'm not happy about it trust
me
i'm miser everyone listening right now
is listening for you and they've never
heard of me i'm fully aware of this
and i'm fine with it but i'm just so
curious like should we play it because
for
me like sorry i feel like i'm held back
by
ah but it's gonna be so much trouble
like ah but is it really gonna work like
you're just like
i'm gonna hang from the sky in a bun
playing a violin
dancing and there's no backing down
like every meeting i'd back down more
and more and be like okay i don't have
to hit it could just be a
it can be like half you know what i mean
you never backed down
somehow you know it's funny because when
i first decided i wanted to do this i
saw it in a cirque du soleil show which
my managers now don't let me go to
cirque du soleil shows like you're not
supposed to go to the cirque show and
come away with like a
like i want to do no yeah you're
supposed to be like wow
you go to cirque to watch that and you
never attempt it and yeah yeah you go
like that's for them
that is for like special trained
performers to do this their entire life
but somehow i walked out of this cirque
show and i saw this gal do a hair
hanging routine and i was like
i could do that while playing the violin
i know it i could do this
meanwhile she's got like straps holding
like
they've got a whole rig that you don't
know about
so any you know covet is happening i
felt like so much was taken away from me
like all of us and here i was sitting at
home i'm gonna die soon
the world is over so what can i do so i
was like
trying to plan this virtual concert and
i was like what could i possibly do
virtually that would just i want to do
something extraordinary i wanted you
know i want to feel extraordinary in
this performance for my for myself for
my fans and so
i remembered that cirque show i searched
online for hair hanging
people i would love to know what your
algorithm i'd love to know the ads your
computer shows you
after those google searches this is a
switch
i need to re-evaluate so i finally after
much search it's really
difficult to find a hair hanging teacher
and so finally i found
one no shit yeah the things that you
wouldn't surprise i love it
i love there's like a list of jobs of
people that
only you know about which is just such
an interesting list of
careers head hanging specialists yeah
that's at the top
yeah so i i find these teachers i get
them tested i fly them to la so like by
this time i've invested
a lot they were so excited they were
like we're fans of your music
and it was like quite an it's a secret
the head hanging
person gets a call every four years you
know what i mean
like let's be honest any phone call
would have excited these people but
you oh thanks for taking that away
miranda cosgrove she was telling me the
story about her grandmother and this
amazing moment they have and i was like
yeah that doesn't add up i don't like
you couldn't have gotten that like i had
to pick apart the story and she was like
well that was a very special she's like
you're ruining my relationship with my
grandmother i was like oh sorry continue
so they come to la they like teach me to
do the hair it's like i'm so excited
and you're on a stage getting them no no
we're at my house in
la and we go out and i was like perfect
they were like the first time
we just need a beam or something that
you can like put weight on from so we go
out i have this little like
jungle gym in my backyard and so i'm
just in the backyard
and i clip in and i just like put a
little bit of weight like i basically
bend my knees my feet are still planted
on the ground and my
eyes just got so wide and i looked at
them and i was like
isn't the like because it was quite an
in-depth hairstyle like it took us
over an hour to do my hair yeah it's a
bun with like
with braids with braids and then yeah it
has to be like combed perfectly so the
hair all just distributes
yeah okay and does your hair have to be
a certain length um it was a little bit
longer than this and it was like
barely long why am i t helping you teach
people how to do that
do not do it is my my advice and anyway
so i'm just like
wasn't that the hair supposed to help
and i'm thinking they must have done my
hair wrong and the girl just looks at me
and she's like
well i mean no it's it still is going to
be extremely painful
and i just like any idiot would know
that but here i am just like
what i'm feeling like they lied to me
you know and they're like well
and then i was like tears remember the
violin was hard
yes yeah so yeah and i remember thinking
after that first day like i didn't even
like lift my feet from the ground and
i remember i was like i cannot go back
tomorrow and do this again
but the idea that you're building up a
tolerance of pain
yeah and it's also just kind of mind
over matter you learn that you're not
going to rip your hair out and your
scalp's not going to rip off
and then the survival instinct is old
it's not helping me
interesting kind of like because i asked
you know the second day i asked her i
was like
does it get easier and she was like it
doesn't get less painful you just
understand the pain you just get used to
the pain you understand that it's not
going to
harm you like because you've done it
before and so but the only reason i went
back for that second
and third and fourth lesson is because
i'd hired them for a week to teach me
and i was too embarrassed to not show up
like they'd just flown across the
country to be there i got the
hotel like i paid them i was too
embarrassed to be like
never mind like i'm a pussy i can't do
it yeah i i'm not even gonna try again
so i'm sorry i just realized um that you
people are fucking nuts
uh this is an insane idea and we're in a
pandemic and never mind
apologies we're all going a little crazy
i have a flight for you
yeah if you guys have not seen anyone in
six months the first person i decided to
see was a hair hanging
expert uh who i flew out for a week and
i'm hanging from my gymnasium
uh yeah no that would be but that's that
can i tell you
fear of embarrassment again that is kind
of a
uh um quality that i try not to over
pathologize some of the best
things the things i'm most proud of i
was afraid of being embarrassed i was
afraid of people thinking i couldn't do
it and i did it
and that's a great driving force that is
like if that's where you find your
motivation in that moment
yeah that's why every man that's ever
killed a woman has done it
it's a very strong i i was
i too seriously being embarrassed people
people are more afraid of being
embarrassed than like
anything than death yes probably that's
true
probably another statistic i just kind
of made out but i know i know is true
because i've seen mine hunter
and it's about serial killers and they
all
killed because their wife or girlfriend
they felt embarrassed in some way
really i know yeah it's okay don't
embarrass anyone no don't embarrass men
they don't like it women being
embarrassed good things happen they work
by our hands
when you did it did you only have like a
cup like how long can you do that
so i once i did it a couple times by the
time my teachers
left i hadn't really i'd only learned to
put weight on it
and so i didn't learn how to do anything
yet so then they leave and i'm like
going to the this like studio by then by
myself and i just clip in and just like
kind of hang around and just like spin
and and i watched enough videos and i
would call the gal that taught me and
ask her questions but i just kind of
taught myself how to
spin and rotate and you know i would
look online and see things people had
done
and anyways kind of made this routine so
okay this is because there's just so
many reasons to give up here and you
just
didn't like what is that like there's
just a like
this is too hard but i'm not gonna give
up
you know i just feel like i've faced
this like feeling of this is impossible
several times before that means i'm
close and that means it means i'm closer
it means i'm just in the first
phases you know it's like i just haven't
learned it yet and
i remember this is hard yeah learning
the vitality it felt impossible when i
started i vaguely remember but i
remember it feeling
like how could your pinky possibly do
that you know like
still doesn't make sense but yeah and
then it was like i remember doing magic
like i did a magic routine once on tour
and i wanted to like
appear out of this magic box and i
learned how to do it i was like this is
impossible
yeah and it hurts but i learned how to
do it and suddenly it wasn't and so it
hurts to pop out of a box
it was kind of well i was hanging i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna give away the
tricks of the trade i mean the hair
hanging was definitely the most painful
and mind over matter thing i'd done
and i think also it just kind of came at
a time when i was so discouraged from
covid and everything i needed
for myself to prove that like because i
mean everybody that loved me told me
please give up please yeah yeah please
stop because like
i mean not only i was afraid my hair
would rip out but i was like really
afraid i might injure my neck yeah it it
let that's it it's just all that weight
just like
and having to be clear that you have so
much control of your body and like
seeing videos before that you're like
okay she knows what she's doing but
if i had just seen that and knew nothing
about you i'd be like this is
it is scary right i was i was kind of
terrified for my neck and just how much
pain like
you know and i went to a specialist was
like is there anything wrong in there
like after a few times
but you know finally i just realized
every time i clipped in
it was going to feel impossible and it
took about 20 minutes to feel like i
could do it every single time
um your head goes numb afterwards
that's what they didn't tell you you'll
go nuts hang in there
you'll go numb any day now that's pretty
much yeah once you kind of went numb you
know and when we filmed this we did it
enough times that like
i mean i think i was hanging for about
an hour to do this because we had to get
all the angles and you know but
there's not like because i'm like she
must have stopped down after every
i was like looking at the cuts being
like she must have stopped and they must
like it's just you did it the whole time
and more well the problem
is is that like once you take the weight
off it's like the blood rushes back to
your head
oh when you get off it does it feel like
you're floating yes
yes even more so than when you're
actually floating
yeah so we i told the guys i was like
once we start filming we don't stop
because i if i take the pressure off
like i can't start it it's too hard to
start again
who do you look at besides cirque du
soleil and are like
fuck they're doing some cool shit oh
pink which i know
that's what i was just thinking oh i
love pink so much have you been to one
of her concerts
oh no i was at the vm grammys or
something where she's
she's on the ceiling there's no net
at the grammys there was no net yeah
she's she does it in her shows too
she's insane i i mean it's wild
yeah she's on what is it called is it
called acrobatic yoga or so it's like
it's like some crazy silks tumbling in
fabrics in the sky
with no net yeah looks
very intense she's so cool i love pink
and she just her attitude about
life like everything about her i'm just
like
no fucks no fucks no she doesn't care
you just want to be i'm like i want to
go to lunch with her i just want to be
her friend
we now take a moment in your regularly
scheduled program
i.e me interrupting lindsay sterling
i'm going to interrupt myself this time
how do you do that
me too me doing ads is just me
interrupting myself
you guys i'm gonna talk about daily
harvest um
uh yeah this episode i feel like i was
interrupting a lot so i feel the need in
this outbreak
to say you guys want to hear benton and
emily talk you interrupted your own show
where you were constantly interrupting
to talk about daily harvest my life is
super busy
my lifestyle we're really busy we're all
busy i'm very busy i go to work i take
care of family and pets
oh yeah i am busy do you understand
well none of that is true he's reading
the copy ha
nope have you heard about it that's
definitely true
have you heard about daily harvest i
have because i'm so busy i use it well
they deliver delicious food all built on
organic fruits and vegetables right to
your door it literally takes minutes to
prepare and i never have to think twice
if the food i'm eating is good for me
i had one this morning me too i was
really busy and grabbing on the way out
i had ginger and greens but i wasn't
nearly as busy
i had uh those cookie dough balls oh
how come i don't know about those where
are those we ate them on the show once
on camera
oh they were delicious
yeah was that one of the lost the last
weeks of my life in the last all i know
is that i have lost weeks
all i know is that i'm really busy and i
love daily harvest
because they don't use yeah it's very
busy because they don't use
preservatives added sugars artificial
anything
and they have this new almond milk wait
why is it spelled m-y-l
because it's almond milk is that a new
thing like another pronoun i need to
learn
milk with a why is that new yeah that
belongs to them like my okay ma'am
you say her story now like is this a new
word
well assignment let's not make it
political okay um it's just their new
milk and it's really delicious when
you're on the go and you're very busy
and you if you're busy you can get
started today and go to dailyharvest.com
and enter promo code good for you
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code good for you for 25
of your first box at dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com
but is it daily or weekly like how often
is that somebody else's slogan
whose slogan is that how does it deliver
it's up to you
how often can you have you could get it
it comes in a big fro like i do the
shakes right so it comes in a frozen box
dry ice very exciting delivery comes
once a week
pick new shakes every week whatever i
want bam you want ginger and greens at
your door bam you want spearmint bam
i put the dry ice in my cauldron all
right
sign up for this you guys sold me well
you're already signed up for it so i
hope you are
well you sold me sold
oh my god read an anaconda i'm going to
give you kayla smash this
right now so i can go pass out
helix mattresses there's a sleep quiz
you take did you know this
i didn't know about this quiz you've
told me about this before i love we've
taken ads
we've taken conversations the quiz are
you sleepy
can you move your hand please trump hold
on emily emily
hold on we have that on camera right now
emily just went are you sleepy
stop doing it on camera sorry how do you
sleep do something
i feel like you're i feed this you sleep
like a fetus
i do i knew it inside of a woman
i wish i've been trying to get back in
my mom's uterus for 36 years remember
when in the revenant leonardo dicaprio
cut the horse open and got inside
so colorful i know it always makes me
think that i sleep on my back back
no one sleeps like me i sleep on my back
really
but but do you do hands uh by your side
on your
chest that's how i sleep that's so
strange
that's my sleep i wonder if we took the
same sleep quiz if we didn't get the
same bed we did it we got different beds
because we like different
strengths i have a terrible mattress
anyways he looks like the sleep clothes
you can take it takes two minutes
oh no perfect we're selling these
products to you we already have all
these
oh fabulous okay everybody is unique and
helix knows that so if you go take their
sleek quiz they'll tell you what kind of
mattress you need soft medium firm
all the mattresses are really great they
keep you cool so you're not hot when you
sleep
helix is like really cool just go to
helixsleep.com
whitney take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it for a hundred
nights risk free they'll even pick it up
if you don't like it
what yeah but you will like it you'll
love it helix is offering up to two can
we find a way the guy that picks
it up later is a postmate
we don't have potential for the sponsor
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars of all mattress orders and
doordash is a sponsor fuck posters
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
whitney good night
[Laughter]
by the way just leave this in this is
the third time today i've almost drank a
candle
and they were lit the first two times so
i also i was listening to
i i try to not listen to anyone's
interviews before i talk to them as you
may have noticed
um i don't like things to feel super
interviewy but i was listening to one
that you
had where you were saying like i was in
a
orchestra and then uh you decided to get
we kind of talked about it i'm sort of
obsessed with the moment that people
have
and i still don't know if i've totally
had it where you realize
without any like ego or
um narcissism when you're like
uh no i think i've hit this moment but
then i get scared and relapse sometimes
where you're like no i'm not meant to be
here i meant to be
the only person what i mean yeah
where it's not it's not like it's
it's true but we've been and maybe it's
just a girl thing where we've been
uh uh sort of uh conditioned to believe
like
don't take up too much space don't shine
too bright don't you know what i mean
like it took me a while to not feel
like guilt when i was on stage or
something like
you know um but maybe it's different you
know with what you do because you're
you know yeah always talented
you know though i remember the very like
a very specific moment that like
changed i feel like my trajectory and it
was when i was in high school i was a
senior
i was trying to earn money for college
and i found out like some recruits came
to recruit at my school for the junior
miss pageant
you know who would have thought that the
juniors pageant would like kind of
change the way i looked at where i
wanted to go
but i was like listening to what they
talked about and i was like i've never
considered myself a pageant girl i was
like but i can do all that stuff
can i tell you i'm sorry pageants yes
i'm the first
i'm the first person i have a million
jokes about pageants being dumb whatever
but
for young people it's like i from what i
understand it really builds a lot of
confidence
absolutely it's not about like i mean
whatever you want it great like no one's
gonna like hire you later because you
were
got this place in this pageant but what
it just does for kids confidence and
like performing
in front of people like absolutely like
and that's why i didn't want to do it at
first because all the stigma around
pageant but i remember doing it they
taught us like interviewing skills they
taught us how to be poised on stage in
front of an audience like
it taught a lot of skills that were
really helpful in the future but also
there was a talent category which i was
like
i mean you weren't in a bathing suit you
know what i mean that's right it's like
that's the only thing that ends up
people like
right we didn't make women walk in
swimsuits
that is the part where like this feels
like a chauvinistic show every woman no
matter how
there's like a little like it's just
like your inner thighs
they're gonna i mean it's i don't walk i
when i walk to the bathroom
naked with my dude i put a thing around
my waist
i can't walk in naked or in front of
anyone i'll be naked
but i'm not going to walk naked is that
not
no one's relating to me no i think so
i've just never like actually
like heard anybody say it but it's so
true i don't ever want at the beach
i don't like if i'm gonna go to the surf
and i'll take the
towel to the surf get out yeah and then
walk very or wait till
or i'll wait till someone's looking the
other way and then side shimmy like i
i'm a big crab walker i'm a crab one
yeah
i just am like yeah i don't even know
where i get why i'm on this tangent
well swimsuits yes yeah that's what it
is
it's like it's the swimsuit you're
making women walk
in high heels oh bye dude no thanks but
luckily they didn't have that in the one
i did so i didn't have to do the
swimsuit on the junior mist didn't you
didn't have a bikini competition yeah
that would be a question lame
school you went to so they did have like
this talent portion of course i'm like
i'm gonna play a classical violin piece
but
when we were like prepping and i saw
there was several violinists
quite a few actually surprisingly and
they were all playing these concertos
and they were all really good
and i thought to myself how am i
possibly going to stand out as one of
five violinists playing some random
concerto and i remember talking to my
mom and i was like i just wish i could
do something fun
like there's dancers that are dancing i
want to do fun things and she was like
well make the violin fun she was
probably really annoyed that i'm saying
this about a skill that
she helped me develop with like you know
so much paying for lessons paying for
violins in here she's like
oh and it's not fun enough for you so
she was like well then make it fun
we've all invested in this yes you're
you're doing this
you've made your bet in l.a yeah i can't
imagine the stress
of having your daughter who you've paid
for violin lessons to for years like i
don't really want to do this
no you're doing it you're going to get
forever this is your
vocation pretty much and so i
took that though and i thought okay well
i could make a rock song for the violin
and i got some friends to like
play their guitars and like drums and i
wrote this little rock songs the first
song i'd ever written
and i decided i would move around on the
stage you can't even call it dancing i
would just say like
timed movement where i'd like put my hip
to the side and i'd like
wink and i'd like cock my head you know
like but it was the most like
rudimentary movement to this little rock
song that i wrote and a little
jump here and it's also funny to me i
love hearing this
part of the story but i it is funny that
the story is like i was just trying to
make playing violin less uncomfortable
but now that i know how uncomfortable it
is i sort of feel like you're just like
okay yeah this feels okay let me give my
nega break okay
like i'd rather physically be running
around than just standing here
getting a fucking sciatica oh it does
give a little freedom
and so i just remember doing this on
this you know playing this rock song and
i had no idea how anyone was going to
react because you know
i was like no one's going to expect this
are they going to be uncomfortable
are they going to i didn't know what the
reaction was going to be but people were
smiling and they you know they they were
little roots and you know cheers which
for a classical violinist you never get
a whoa
in the middle of your amazing
performance and i just was like wow
that was fun like i had a blast
and i have to figure out how to like
chase something like this and that was
like a huge moment for me when the
violin went from being just like
this is what i do to like oh my gosh
this is what i want to do
i feel like actively yeah and i mean
it's just it's i do think there's a
little bit
i think i touched on this earlier and
lost my train of thought but there's a
little bit i'm seeing an epidemic
of this next generation thinking
everything should be really easy
yes because i don't know if they're like
looking on social media and they're just
seeing people
winning at a young age and it's giving
them a dysmorphic idea of what it takes
do you know what i mean like i love when
people are successful to you and they're
like i just worked
my ass off since i was five and you're
like
that's how it goes that's how a
sustainable career goes but i just feel
like
i'm around so many people they're like
well how come i don't have this and
you're just like
because you've been doing it for two
years right don't let instagram fool you
or psych you out
just work harder than anyone and i
promise you will get everything you want
i love that and it's and there's nothing
to be said that like you don't have to
start when you're five because a lot of
people in their later life are like well
i want to
do something now i just tell myself that
to justify why i'm not talented at
skilled
tasks oh but yes you are and you're like
in what you do and like asking so yeah
don't don't self-deprecate like that
thank you don't do that you know what
they don't talk about my friend like
that
i like that i love that
but that is such a great way you
actually you're so good at this because
um when people self-deprecate or
disparage themselves
it's this weird moment now where you're
like we know what that does
and we know that every self-deprecation
is a little tiny cut to the soul or the
spirit or the self-worth and you're
teaching other people how to talk to you
and all that kind of stuff
and so now when someone does it's like
oh because i'm an idiot like i want i
you just perfectly said that to me in a
way that didn't make me feel defensive
because i was you don't want to tax them
you know you're just that was amazing oh
you're so you're so sorry i just was
like fuck i need to
stop doing that where's like when
sometimes when i see people i'm like
don't talk about yourself like that
and then they're like now i feel bad and
i was joking and it's a habit and you do
it too
what the fuck like i i think because i
have so much um
like an anger just resentment about how
long i did that to myself when i see
someone else doing it
yeah yeah and they're just like but you
just handled that with such grace
they're so nice well thank you
but i do feel that well it's funny
because i played the violin since i was
like you know
six five but i didn't start dancing
until i was in my 20s
you know and it was merely because i had
that experience on stage was jumping
around and people
liked it and i had fun and so i thought
well how far can i push this envelope
and so then it turned into like little
bits of choreography and then i was like
i bet i could
spin and play you know so i it's like
anything can be developed but it took
years nonetheless and so much work
i just i love it because it's like you
know stuff like stand-up stuff like
like i mean creating your own genre of
like
this and like all the amazing things
you're seeing people do online
like it they there was a point where
they couldn't
do it absolutely it's just weird to
think about that i don't know why it's
just sort of like
i couldn't do it either then i figured
it out dude
when people say about stand up they're
like i can never do that i'm like no i
couldn't either
no one can until they work for 10 years
on it you know what i mean no one can
yeah
absolutely like i don't know why there's
a little bit like and maybe it's just
because we're in this like
like clip culture where we're only
watching little three-minute clips or
where people aren't getting in-depth
about like what they went through it's
just like sort of everyone we're seeing
we're just seeing them when they've
arrived at their destination
right you know absolutely and it's like
and i think you did post on youtube uh
of like a blog of how you did the hair
thing right yes
see i love that you do that to like
demystify it to go like it took
all this hard work right do you know
what i mean well that was one of the
another reason that i was like i want to
do this because i
really wanted to post that vlog i'd been
working on it and i was like
i want to prove that you can do hard
things and i like this
such a disappointing vlog if at the end
i'm like and i quit
that's really actually very amazing to
to
film yourself doing the thing you're
trying to accomplish just so you're like
i've shot all this i guess i have to do
the thing all this footage i've already
started editing it's a great story it's
going to make people cry it's going to
make people great
it's so good you like trapped yourself
so you had so many ways
also this was part of a show and i had
no other creative for this moment and i
was like if i don't
do this hair hanging what am i going to
do in that moment i mean i could have
just played the song
but yeah in my mind i was like no i
wanted to this was going to be a
spectacular moment
i love that you're like i have to go
above and beyond yeah
especially you know for something
honestly it's like
i really do think it was just so much
had been taken away from so many people
and i wanted to prove to myself that
like i can do this and
and i do totally agree with what you say
sometimes we look online it makes look
everything look like it's easy yeah and
there's a quick fix to everything but
really things that last and things that
make you lastingly proud like i'm so
proud of this
experience because it was hard and
you're also making me realize like i do
think that like i've had a little bit of
like trepidation in the youtube space
like
because i come from like this old school
like traditional media thing
and um but you also people like dude i
put up
was i'm being uh shadow band my video's
not getting in the algorithm reviews
yet because it sucks so but i'm just
saying you're showing it like
to get big on youtube if everyone thinks
they just need to like record something
and like talk about what they had for
breakfast you're like putting in
you know incredible production quality
and making i mean this is like the shit
you see on mtv when i was in the 90s
like
great stuff shit that like blows your
mind you know like i think that a lot of
people look at youtube as like
i'll just drop this here and i'll just
drop this here while i'm waiting for the
this is now the big thing
right like you're treating it absolutely
in a way that is just like it is just so
um professional
and i just think that i know but i'm
just thinking everyone i've met that's
big on youtube
is a fucking pro and they work their ass
off and they have a whole
like it's not like youtube is for people
that want to just kind of half
give a shit right the ones that make it
are treated like a business and are
so fucking professional you know it's
interesting how the culture has changed
because when youtube first came about in
those first few years when
people were first realizing oh my gosh
you can have a platform an audience here
those people worked so hard you know and
the culture of social media in the
beginning was
like you had to be a hustler you know
and it is kind of sad to me that the
culture of social media is now very much
like what's the quick fix what's the
because i'm like in the beginning it was
just a bunch of people who had been kind
of rejected from a lot of other
platforms and wanted to
wanted to do it anyway and were
resilient enough to be like well and go
to this space and wow you can just start
doing it yourself it was like the best
talent show in the world it was like
everyone that like hollywood didn't know
what to do with
doing something incredible and you're
just like why the fuck am i
watching people act like they can do
this on tv why don't i just watch the
people to do it
and then you know it's just so
passionate people on there it's like the
people that would normally be the stunt
double
in the movie like i want to just see
them keep
going yeah no it's true and i
i feel like the people that have lasted
from that it is just
you know they they're pros you also have
to be a business person
do you know what i mean like i think
there's a little bit now um
uh you know i'm just realizing the
common denominator and everybody that
does
really well on youtube like they fucking
take it seriously
and work their asses off and they don't
have any entitlement around like well
this why didn't this do better like
people are going to keep watching the
people that have thrilled them and
be and i almost said be dazzled i want
to say dazzle them
so or be dazzled i mean why not
please don't bedazzle anyone without
their consent um
you know like it's like people you have
built this trust
and it's just like you can't take a day
off from building that trust like you
can't just go like there's a pandemic
i'm gonna stop
delivering like you just deliver in such
an amazing way it's inspiring to me
well thank you thank you i love
delivering my inspiring things so what's
wrong with you what are your
problems why are you so together oh gosh
i wish i you know i don't think anyone
feels like they are together you know
like i
i do oh let's be honest i mean i'm
together well that's good i think we can
all agree 100
we could all agree okay yeah you noticed
i looked for validations like really
yeah no i mean if you you do not seem
like i mean i'm as someone that just is
sort of the paragon of mental health
yes oh mental health i feel like that is
a constant battle yeah that we all have
to face
and if you know i think by realizing
that it's a constant battle i am so much
better off
like back before i knew i had any sort
of constant battle with it
yeah i think that i was i just didn't
understand what was happening and
you know i'm so grateful for the crazy
experiences mentally that i've gone
through because
they've allowed me to like i guess
understand like you know
we're all constantly going through ups
and downs in our brain and
i don't know it's really helped me
because i mean i went through anorexia
years ago and i went through
pretty severe depression and you know
it's something now that is a part of my
life and i just know how to manage it
it does not control me it will never
control me again but it's like now i
understand you
a little eating disorder and i
understand you depression and anxiety
and i i have a much better really you're
not invited here yeah you're not you're
not welcome you do better when you're
alone in the basement
yeah because they get to come upstairs
it is it's like
it's like a little friend that's
unwanted that just keeps like trying to
revisit you just say no no you can't
come in
and i think personifying my eating
disorder helped me
so much like i read a book called life
without ed when i was you know kind of
in the thick of it and i was trying to
recover
and um it like this girl that wrote the
book
she named her eating disorder and she
would have like conversations
with it and so as crazy as that sounds i
started doing that and i would
not crazier than the things i was doing
when i had an eating disorder like
exactly that's what's so amazing about
it so i
i mean i had you know i wrote a book
about it and all that um uh
about uh having eating disorders and
stuff and um i remember when i was like
17 or
because i would go to these they'd send
me these eating disorder
experts and i would spend the whole time
just lying to them and
scamming them and i would like put like
i'd wear like like extra pairs of pants
to look heavier i used to go in
before uh the interview because they
would weigh me every time i went in and
i would drink like five
big giant fiji waters and go in and get
weighed and i would like and they'd be
like oh you gained six pounds like i
fucking had that shit
down to a science like scamming these
motherfuckers and um
because your brain is like you know it
really is
in a lot of ways you know they say this
about alcoholism or any kind of ism like
it's the disease that tells you you
don't have a disease you know like you
know
it doesn't it's like i don't know how to
explain it but it's like now when i see
people with like disordered eating or
something and i'm
and i see them and i have so much love
because i'm like i thought i was getting
away with it too
you know what i mean like i had a whole
system where i thought i had like
you know my napkin and i would like tap
the oil off the vegetable at the
restaurant and then
like put the bread in the purse and i
like truly thought i was getting away
with it like that's how
you know these kind of addictions like
they make you so dysmorphic about what
other people
can even perceive do you know what i
mean like right well you don't
even realize that the real person that's
being fooled is you yes and that like
you're lying to yourself constantly and
believing the lies
and believing it and they don't seem
like lies like it's true like
it's so hard and i have other family
members that you know deal with it but
yeah and then
and then i was watching an interview
with you and i i related so much and
like you just put it in the words that i
i feel like i never was able to find
elegant words for like
how you would sort of um
uh kind of trick yourself in by
by convincing yourself what you were
doing was super healthy oh absolutely
same thing i was like i'm vegan now and
i'm not eating meat or sugar
or dairy exercise all the time
which means nothing no food i'm like i
don't eat dairy carbs protein but like
fat rice anything and it was all like
well i'm just healthy you guys
yeah yeah taking care of my body and and
i'm exercising a ton
yeah doodle dash um door dance excuse me
it's a good business idea that it's
called prostitution it's called shark
tank
not d diddling is you know i don't know
let's move on
don't you forget that one thing at the
store now you can get snacks drinks in
household essentials in 30 minutes i'm
saying no
emily i've never did you done anything i
don't know about you i don't forget
things
oh yeah that's right because you have an
assistant that reminds you
sometimes i go through a drive-through
and then i think i should have got more
chicken nuggets and then i use doordash
to bring them to me
so i don't embarrass myself by going
back around like hey can i get four more
there's always i ordered six but i
wanted ten i used to go buy all the
swiss miss hot chocolates from a grocery
store and i'd be so embarrassed that i
would come back in like a hat the next
day and like crazy makeup
you should have come back like leader
yes
doordash connects you to restaurants you
love right now and right to your door
and you can get the groceries and
essentials you also love with doordash
you can get drinks snacks household
items they'll bring you all the stuff
that you don't want to leave your home
for
ordering is easy they go right up to
your door it's contact
contactless delivery
contactless delivery he just doordashed
some vodka
when i got covered i door dashed a
heating pad right to my back
um i think that let's talk about
cheesecake let's really quick hold on
stop let's go around and say this status
doordass purchase
i've done like like two avocados before
they don't hate you yeah they don't like
i've just dashed someone to talk to oh
pregnancy test is probably the yeah i've
definitely done that plan b oh
cheeseburgers that's my plan b
i ordered cheesebuzz once just one can
that sounds like a fucking
fun night you weren't there
that's right you're right you're right
so it was it was just whizzy
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 wait a minute we didn't even tell
them there's 300
000 partners to choose from and you has
puerto rico canada in australia
and one of those partners includes the
cheesecake factory yes
remember we were just talking about how
much we wanted to go there i love it in
salt lake city
they have a they have chicken and
biscuit doordash that to your house but
you know what i just noticed in most
podcasts people but we were just talking
about that and they're
lying to jesus we really we're
yes we're in a feature film now for a
limited time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app and enter
code whitney 2021
that's 25 off up to a 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your air force order
when you download the door dash app in
the app store and enter code whitney2021
don't forget that's whitney2021 for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject change term supply and if you're
door dashing something less than 15
take a good hard look at yourself was
anybody impressed with how fast i read
that
i was i literally was like i feel like
this is the first time
like i've done this business you're like
i fucking
got school okay like that was incredible
i was incredible am i
i don't know should i do this for a
living
i've been taking virtual vitamins for
years like like since
two years before this podcast okay and
this is how three years
yeah let me think if you're not
if you're not watching i'm about to hurt
myself don't try this at home yeah
oh wow oh are you like now what
okay well now we need to buy another
ritual vitamin good thing they come
right to your door every month
good thing they just delivered right to
your door for all the essentials you
need and you know exactly what's in them
because they're not trying to hide
nothing from you
ritual is a multivitamin reimagined oh
god sorry i want them to see ritual is
made traceable ritual is designed with
your life stage in mind
ritual makes healthy habits easy these
are all things you should know about
ritual
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering
whitney's listeners 10 off during your
first three months visit ritual.com
whitney to start your ritual today but
first i'm going to try to throw this in
emily's mouth and first of all the
ritual they look like mini lava lamps
look look how they turn over and they're
like oh yeah that's fine they're like
caviar
yeah they literally had my tuck out of
my mouth for five minutes okay ready
you're looking for is that different
than normal
okay right
okay that was you after falling the
other day
i have a band-aid on my head okay can
you not hurt yourself okay i'm gonna
describe this for listeners we threw
that out that was a horrible picking up
another ritual vitamin
whitney's holding it she's throwing it
aggressively oh she got it
is it a minty oh my gosh it is
love it loves that thanks ritual i was
thinking about you because i was
watching your interview
and you don't know the assembly i don't
think but nick remembers when i
only ate carrots and barbecue sauce for
like two years did you turn orange
i do sorry i turned orange i did the
same thing
i was also had an addiction to bad self
tanner at the time so i don't think i
would have known
oh yeah cause if you eat too many
carrots you'll turn orange i was a
that is so funny yeah um
uh did that happen to you yes my sister
i think this is my rock bottom what is
wrong with you like and you're just a
slightly orange pigment yeah
it shows up like strongly in your hands
she was rubbing my hands at church and
she goes
what did you get out of your hands and i
was like but you know what to tell her
like it's god god is coming for me
i've been punished it's a plague a curse
yeah in church of all places to notice
something crazy like that
like oh shit
[Laughter]
i just like i mean i think i look back
at like how much time i lost i look back
at like how much i wish i had talked
about it sooner
like publicly because i felt all this
guilt because i was like on a tv show
and i was like
like my thighs like didn't touch like my
i was just so impressive
i don't know how everyone talks about
the thigh gap but it's not possible
i i have to be honest with you i am
the lindsay sterling of anorexia so yeah
i think i was just a little better at it
than you
shoot don't be filming i'm don't upset
you're very talented a lot of things
that just wasn't you wasn't
very
[Laughter]
oh my gosh but it is um yeah it's just
like such a it's i just think it's like
the fact that i don't talk about it more
i even feel shame about because i think
for the longest time i was like
i lived through it i don't want to have
to be like the spokesperson for it and i
don't have to talk about eating
disorders or disordered eating because
that's the craze that it's kept popping
up in other ways for me you know
it's like whack-a-mole where it's like
oh my gosh yes it manifested itself in
so many different areas
and it comes from that like
perfectionism side of like probably our
personalities
and i remember like you know it started
with food and then one time i remember i
was treating sleep
like an eating disorder i was like did
you do the same thing
like i just got if you were supposed to
get eight hours i would only allow
myself six months i was just saying
sleep you speak up because i don't sleep
at night but yes i see what you mean
it's the self-deprivation i just kept
cutting back
until i just wasn't sleeping because i
just had to prove that i could like the
same way it's like calories like cutting
down it was
i don't know and i've done it in
multiple ways in different areas so it's
like that's that's a big thing of like
when you get into recovery and it's this
it's such a miracle because you're like
oh
like because i think also it's like when
you realize other people are doing it
it's not as special and there's also
like oh
there's a relief because so much of it
is the isolation so much of it is the
i'm gonna isolate so no one has to see
any of this and i can like live in my
no one's gonna challenge my delusions
and you don't realize how isolated you
got i mean i think
all through college i didn't have
friends i was like in my
room eating dried mangoes like counting
them like i was like
it was my best friend it was my life
well it's because eating disorders are
so isolating because so many social
activities revolve around that's
correct and so it's like friends invite
you out for dinner and you're just like
well
i would always keep the place how could
i possibly hide that i actually have
like
a theory that i like subconsciously got
into
stand up and working at night so i had
an excuse to be like well i'm just i can
only stop by for 30 minutes
yeah no an already you know always
already 88 on the way
it is interesting how there were all
these little like pre-meditated plans
and
when you have those kind of premeditated
plans all the time
you realize like slowly you've lost all
the capacity to do anything else
because you're so focused on that and
only that that's why relationships can't
be genuine and real because
when you're having a conversation in the
back of your mind you're actually
thinking about your next plan
and about the next so it's like nothing
was counting i would go
i'd put everything i ate for the day on
a plate or
be like imagine like yeah counting this
is how much i've done this is how much i
can eat
exactly are like whoa i can't stay here
very much longer because i gotta get
home so i can run before i need to have
sex with
either when you have sex or so i can
burn calories or i need to leave
it's always it was i revolved around
food and exercise exactly and it was
always like dates were always like hikes
that's safe like you know like i was
just like it it really did and you're
also
um yeah you're driving such a wedge in
your relationships
um which is so tricky and like
but i do think for people like us that
have that thing
like that you know and after you being
in recovery for
you know various addictions for so long
like it's
here's the good news like when you come
out on the other side the thing that
made you so good at that
maladaptive behavior dude if you can
just
re-route the energy refocus the most the
most brilliant people i know the most
successful people i know
have struggled with this in some
capacity you know what i mean absolutely
part of the adversity is part of why
they're such great artists but it's like
the brains that make us do those things
are also the brain
that makes you do what you're doing on
my screen right now hanging up and
around you know what i mean
right it's like it's so i just i always
help i always want to tell people like
oh my god
you had to go to treatment for this
congratulations you're going to be so
successful because you have the brain
wiring
do you know what i mean like if we put
because that's why i thought i was like
if i put all the energy i'm putting into
like counting
calories and going to five different
grocery stores and like secretly
ordering this
fucking crisp bread from germany that
has no calories i mean i was like order
it like i was like
ordering crazy shit i put so much it was
a full-time job
absolutely like if i put as much work
into this thing
that's ruining my life into something
that could be good for my life like
imagine how good it would be
right you know and anybody that is
struggling with any sort of like
mental illness whether it's anorexia or
anxiety or like anything that feels
debilitating
i just always love to say that there is
so much hope you know like what you're
saying
there is recovery and it's so worth it
with the internet you can reach out to
people and have
fellowship yeah and like more than
anything i remember just finally having
to admit to myself that it was worth it
because at first it
like that you sort of felt so protecting
and it felt like everything you had yeah
yeah yeah you know but you have to
finally admit to yourself or learn in
your own way that like
this has stolen everything from me and
it is not
worth it it is we delude
it's like you're deluding yourself but
it's also not
conscious so i think it's important that
people know it's like you're lying to
yourself like no one wakes up and it's
like i'm gonna lie to myself
it's not it's totally unconscious and
it's like you know i think it's
important that people
understand that with something like
eating disorders it's like it's never a
moral failing it's never a
um active choice a lot of this shit is
inherited in ancestral trauma
or from something that happened to the
kid it could have not been your parents
or it's just your personality right and
that's how it came together like it
doesn't you know it's like some people
you know this are drinking some people
are throwing up some people are start
everyone's got a thing right and the re
the reason you think you're alone and
having your thing is because you're
alone
because you're isolating yourself right
that's where we get that idea that we're
alone i haven't talked about it because
we've all
isolated alone and no one's going hey
do you want any chance to eat like 40
carrots today with barbecue sauce uh
and most of them would go no but i have
had 45 cauliflower
in a weird smoothie you know what i mean
everyone's got their thing it's just
that we're also ashamed of it that we
don't talk about it
right so that's why we think we're the
only ones that have the thing
right absolutely i remember when i went
to a group therapy that was like one of
the most
helpful things for me i sat in this room
with all these girls nothing worse
until you it starts it's funny to think
about like what was it that was so
comforting about
this i think it was controlling me i
know what's going to happen i know it's
going to happen tomorrow
it's like it's that it's this control
thing and you know it's funny because
you think
you know that they're doing it to be
like happier
but i've never been more unhappy than
when i was trapped in there i've never
been
skinnier than i was then but i've never
thought i was uglier
you know it's like everything that you
did it for yeah you know or that i did
it for
yeah actually i've never felt worse
about all those things that i did it for
i never felt like i was fatter i never
felt like i was uglier you know
and yet here i was it's its own drug
absolutely i mean i always think of it
as an addiction for sure it's just an
addiction to like an aversion
and yes and no one that's in active
addiction like you know we say basically
an addiction is defined like when you
stop having fun when it stops being fun
and starts being an obligation
so we all know people have gone through
a thing when you're like i don't want to
drink this firecap but i just six
o'clock and i guess i just have to or
else i'm gonna
like it just becomes an obligation after
a while
absolutely or it's like it's when you
stop controlling it and it starts to
control
you but it is amazing how as soon as i
felt like i was out of the woods i still
say i have disordered eating
um you know because you're never you
know i never know like if something
traumatic happens or someone gets sick
in my family or something bad happens
there i am drinking four diet cokes in a
row
like i will go back to that like very
quickly then i'll go like uh what am i
doing what am i doing but i'm like
that was wild that was great i just like
diet soda diet sun kissed
like sugar-free candies like all the
things that i used to go there like my
little comfort blankie i'll just like go
um but it is amazing how like as soon as
i
was out of it it took me 20 whatever
years
that it controlled my life and then when
i see people now i'm like
cut that don't do that like i like
you know what it was like and you know
how no one could tell you shit
right but when you're out of it you just
want other people to be out of it so bad
that you're just like hey
go to this person here's my therapist
and then i'm just like i need to let you
yeah have the dignity of your own
experience absolutely
and it really is just like i just look
back at my old self and i'm like so
grateful that i was able to find the
resources i found and get through it
because it's like that
like i never would have been happy i
never would have been able to do what
i've done with my career if i was still
like trapped in this like
you know if all my energy was going into
that all my energy and i mean
all my energy yeah i don't think people
understand how all-consuming it is
the irony of yeah absolutely um and
what's going on are you dating someone
i am not i am single in this global
pandemic but i have a great roommate
oh that sounded so sad yeah i bet her
life is awesome just you hanging from
ceilings all the time she's like oh
just on with the paramedics like ah no
we're good we're
i'll try in a couple minutes like her
cops are just wondering if you're gonna
fall to your death from the gymnasium
right yeah no but i will say i've gotten
to spend a lot of time with my family in
the last couple months which has been so
nice like
more so than ever before since like
leaving home so
that's been a positive but yes i am so
single right now and i don't think last
year should count on my
no it doesn't count on your scorecard
last year no i'm still the same age as i
was last doesn't count on your age
either
exactly that's what i'm saying but what
do you how would you
i mean i i do think what like you can't
go and you're too famous to own apps
i actually tried for a second and it was
so strange people would be like wait no
where are you lindsay's
i was like oh this is just so awkward
like not only that
because because first of all what you're
doing when you do that is you're shaming
me
and making me feel like right like what
are you doing on here what are you doing
on
in seven months acrimoniously what do
you mean what am i
doing like people think that that famous
people like have a matchmaker in their
house or something like how do you how
do we meet
people like it's actually harder be
gentler
it's when they shame you for being too
famous for being on the app you're just
like fuck you
man that's what i wrote back and then
seeing him tonight um and then uh but i
do think um
i don't know raya you should get on
maybe yeah
you're on ryan no rya's the one that's
um
hollywood guys in v-necks and fake
photographers and man buns
you love a bun you guys can hang from
buns together
like let me teach you something it is
like a first date
so are you so when was your last
relationship
well it ended last week
three weeks ago but then it like
officially ended like sorry she's
getting kissed she's hitting my computer
she's really
i feel a very inspiring song being
written tonight
a lot of good songs coming your way uh
yes uh yeah so you don't have to talk
about it no it's okay you
can if you want to stop you
yeah that's intense i know yeah
none of my fans even knew i was dating
anyone so they're all gonna be like do
you think they need that i wonder though
with people like you if like part of it
is like
they are in love with you and if they
find out are they going to be like she's
cheated on me
you know what i mean i feel like you
probably have a lot of fans but i think
you're with
them yes
i was just saying i do get letters you
get that feeling yeah
you have many husbands yes in many
states i sometimes get letters
to like my wife lindsay you know so
yeah yeah fine no you are but yeah i
can't find anyone to date me
you're in a full polyamorous
uh mormon relationship that you have
nothing no nothing about it i
have no idea but um but no usually i
know but by the way that's my like
like i do like we get people that are
like think we're married to them and
stuff like that and
like just stay one of those people but
whenever yes they're right there
whenever like someone comments like
you're gonna die alone i'm like i will
have you know about
five people in the pensacola
penitentiary
think i'm their wife that's true you did
used to get
a lot of mail to your home i would throw
them away
because i didn't want to deal with it
and i didn't want her to be scared but
like people would write letters from
penitentiaries to your old address
yeah no i remember your home yeah so the
person that currently lives there
good luck uh i know i always feel like
if you move to a different you should
tell people like hey just you know
creepy packages arrive every once in a
while a lot of people from alcatraz have
my there's a dress so maybe just
put them i don't know like a ring camera
a security guard yeah a lot of people
want to kill me
and they might think you're me so if you
could just not dye your hair blue
uh um funny no well i remember i'm
trying to think no i used to do this for
the longest time
but uh people said when you take ubers
you should never have them
drop you off in front of your house
right so then i'd have them drop me off
down the street at someone else's house
and like a couple said i was like
wait now if i'm just rerouting the
creeps to this other
my neighbor sorry angela who i like
but i didn't i'm so sorry but you know
hopefully they'll just see it's not you
and they won't kill you
for killing someone else there there's
their sites are set on me
so i'm sure they'll be fine so it was
stupid um
but uh uh do you
you can't date yet it's too soon it's
too soon yes
how long was it um we dated for almost a
year yeah
yeah so it's too soon pandemic i don't
think you need to talk about your
relationship though public i mean on
this podcast yes you can
i just mean it doesn't have to be
something you talk about do you mean i
mean i've always
like i said i dated him for a year and i
was kind of getting to that point where
like thank heavens like but i was about
to be like hey you know i'm ready for
this but a lot of times it's just like
that's kind of the one thing i keep
personal in my life i share so much you
should
with my fans you should that's mine
you should yes i the ship has sailed for
me
i owe them everything but you still have
time
you can still get free free usually for
the guys i'm dating because
they don't want to you know they'll get
really interesting messages
when you know so anyways a lot of times
it's funny
they're fine you think so they can
handle it i don't know
yeah they can you think so maybe i've
just been dating the wrong guy
you also know what you're signing up for
so right
it's like it's a little it's like you
know that i do this for a living
yeah you know me so if you want to come
on join the team
here and then tell me you can't
live the way you were living before i
can't yeah that's not it's not my fault
yeah it's just sort of like you know i
don't know someone's gonna pay for this
house
um no i'm just saying like i don't know
i just i don't
feel like uh yeah i just feel like
there's this
um i don't know there's kind of this
pressure or something yeah well i do
feel like it's it is hard for
you to date because it's like and i'm
sure you can relate to this as well at
times where
it's like um i don't want to be in like
this like crazy celebrity scene or
anything like that
you know i just kind of want to date a
normal person but date a man who's
afraid of you
oh that's the trick
i love her breaking the fourth of all
looking and there's four cameras and
there's the only place there isn't a
camera
i just think it's like i i think there's
i've learned a couple things recently
about
relationships no this one i'm gonna
fucking
give it to you mommy has been
accumulating
advice that she will never take for
years and now she's gonna share it i
heard this
actually recently uh that i loved
which is like how do you know you're in
a good relationship um
because i never know and i can justify
anything and i can blame myself i'm
being too sensitive like i'll
i'll kind of like trick myself into
thinking something's working more than
it is
or my bar is just like so low inherently
the shit that i put up with but and i
and i get confused because people say
relationships take work and then people
say it should be effortless and should
be easy and i just get confused like i
just need someone to
say something that's gonna resonate with
my black and white
literal brain and someone finally did
which was
whatever it is mad sad angry jealous
the one thing you should never feel is
confused well i think after any sort of
like
loss like whether it's a breakup or
whatever i think that there's always a
lot of like
self shame that goes into it of like you
know
you just blame yourself for so much and
so much guilt and regret even over
things that like aren't even a thing
yeah so i think having that perspective
of like well you know what i really gave
it you know like looking at the positive
like what does that mean about you as a
person that you were
willing to end it or that you you know
tried so many different things or you
let it last
so long you know rather than focusing on
what you cannot change that is done and
done
it's like well you know don't fill
yourself with shame that's not gonna
make feel any better
nope and if you're if you find yourself
in a relationship where you're trying to
change the person or
uh passive aggressively make comments
until they change the behavior you
well that always works secretly
well also i found that like you know i
don't know sometimes after a breakup
it's like you want to find like almost
not like it was someone's fault but yeah
you just kind of have to realize usually
like it's nobody's fault it's not going
to be it doesn't have to be and yeah
like i think finding fault sometimes
gives you like a little bit of that
closure
of like okay there was a reason for it
like i it
hates you know you always hate when
there's like this open-ended same thing
you're saying about control yeah
i need control over this if i just have
a narrative i can move forward exactly i
can understand it even if it's not true
false sense of security you know i want
to just blame like in whether you're
like well it was my fault or it was
their fault like whatever it is
but i'm like just in this whole
situation i'm going through i kept
trying to find closure and understanding
clarity and fault whether it was me or
him
but finally i was like well this isn't
either of our faults it doesn't have to
be most people genuinely are always
doing the best they can
with what they have that is so big and
like i think most people don't
know and like everything whether it's
like someone treated you badly in
business or this like
it doesn't mean they didn't do something
wrong but most of the time people are
most people are doing the best they can
i don't think anyone wakes up i don't
think except like a few people
for like ted tech and murderers what are
you what did you want
you wanted a water oh no you looked over
there no no oh
she was looking at the exit she was
that's the sign she gives her manager
when she wants to leave there's like a
little
like a fixer why are you fixing your
hair so much oh why is she getting her
purse okay this is like a whole process
you guys worked out no you are you live
here now
um uh but uh i i'm just i'm fascinated
by that because
my big thing cause i i do this thing and
i'm uh
where i do oh i'm gonna make you do it
right now
write down what you want you're going to
take this with you so anyone who's not
in a relationship
and wants to be in one or whatever or
it's between
it is so important you do this okay so i
wrote about this in
my book in one of the uh chapters about
like how you write down
what you want wait you're i have this
list of yours whitney from like 10 years
must would be nice oh nice and red flags
when you meet someone then you just turn
to your list so that your emotion
in your heart is it aren't making the
decisions your brain is making the
decisions
i like that it actually helped me so
much just
writing out what i wanted and what i
didn't want and then
when the person appeared i was like oh
yeah no no
you're the guy you're no no you fit all
these things great like you're not left
to your own devices when you're already
attracted to someone are already
into someone yeah and you already have
all the then you're blind then you're
blind and you're
flying without your cockpit and then
oh dear that came out really
[Laughter]
i'm so innocent and then i say things
all the time that i'm like oh no
i like them by accident
how did she just say the dirtiest thing
on this podcast like damn
right now it's completely i know i feel
like i'm probably turning red i'm like
embarrassed
are you okay you're turning orange red
like the carrots actually sorry yeah
did you eat too many beets this morning
um okay we're going to do this
musts these are musts these are
non-negotiable so when this person comes
to you and you go he's really handsome
i don't really need that thing this is
non-negotiable no matter how handsome
no matter how big his voluptuous man bun
no matter how deep his v-neck must love
a good v-neck um
must um sense of humor humor sense of
humor okay but no
comedians i'm putting that as red flags
comedian
comedian is going under red flags but
says
sense of humor yeah
so she can laugh at you like that yeah
that's how she laughs
i would say good work ethic good work
ethic
wants a family how about this i'm gonna
get real yes he wants family
has a good work ethic and
appreciates and is patient with mine
mine yes
whitney actually doesn't need you here
for this she'll just do no no i got it i
got it you can head out i'll
by the way i'll fax this to you fuck
fuck you for dragging me to a bit that
made me look old
uh patient with my work ethic
because that's a thing you need that is
something definitely i need
um okay um
likes dogs we'll sleep with dogs yeah
that was like number one
dog of the bed some guys are weird about
that
yeah some guys won't even let dogs in
the bed when you're having sex that's so
weird
kidding that is like my number one dogs
are not allowed in the bed during sex
they're not allowed
they go out my kids will never see me
that way
the bed like i can't let my dog see me
being you know
yeah disrespectful
yeah they just lose respect for their
mom dog in the bed
what about touring do you want them to
go on tour with you you
you have to accessible well that's true
flexible the tour
schedule so could come sometimes but not
always yes we'll come visit me on tour
can hang out if they want yes it's fine
if i'm gone
and also is very could go with you have
to get
very granular okay this is the whole
thing because we go i want a guy who's
like nice and
this but you're that's not everyone's
nice sometimes and everyone's
funny sometimes it's like yes i'm
telling you this works
uh as someone who made horrible
decisions most of their life
this after having this like everything
fell into place in my relationship life
okay um uh what was the other thing you
were just
flexible with tor um i would say i love
someone who can tell
a good story huh like i don't know a
good
story okay um
i like that someone that makes i love
that like when people they make other
people feel good about themselves
well that's what i was about to say uh
uh uh like this also should be a person
that
gets along well with others and doesn't
need you to babysit them
yes big thing doesn't need the
babysitter like what would you say that
no
how do we say that in a way that's not
negative um
sufficient yeah self entertaining like
like
the dude i'm with like at a part at a
party i can leave him
i mean it's rude i'll leave him for like
three hours he's like
made friends with everyone like he
doesn't need me there to you know what
i'm saying even if i i don't even
introduce him to the people they don't
even know he's with me
like he has to do all the work for
himself and he's fine and he fucking is
so good at it and i didn't even realize
how much i needed that
to when i go in public with people that
i'm dating that i don't have to take
care of them or think about their needs
or
be like are you okay are you doing like
right they
can't introduce themselves to new people
or whatever like it's something that
yes socially independent socially
independent oh shit the pen broke i
don't know if that's a bad omen
uh oh oh no my man doesn't exist okay
don't worry
it's fine it's fine adversity is good
self
our pen is a paint brush that's it
uh god believes this is all you deserve
i'm sorry and that is the end of it
we don't even get red flags thank you no
except for not a comedian yeah i guess
that's the only one not a comedian yes
red flag comedian
um okay we also can come back as you're
thinking forward because then
red flag is an absolutely no like
absolutely no
someone who you know is for example for
me jealous is a big one i think jealousy
is very hot
but i have so many platonic guy friends
uh
that i've been in relationships where
they're just like or or i don't know if
you have lots of
you know men on your crew when you talk
like for sure if me being around a lot
of men is going to bother you like i
just
not not a good choice don't add to cart
save for later when you're more secure
with yourself
go to therapy and circle back there
that's a good one not jealous
not jealous for people that are making
lists along with us which i expect you
guys to post them and tag me and i will
repost them
it's also so important just getting your
life we do with our careers but we don't
do it in our personal life we go i want
this buy 30. i want
i want to perform on the vmas and the
grammys and i want this award and i want
this
you probably didn't want any of it but
you got all of it uh oh no i made my
vision okay good i was saying most
people
have to set goals you are just like i'm
gonna um but yeah like
you in personal life we don't do that we
don't do like i want this kind of person
and this no
i read a book called the soulmate secret
i think
did you recommend it to me yeah dina
recommended it to me it's really good
and for anyone out there who is finding
themselves in this spot of like
wanting a relationship it's basically
kind of like the book the secret but
it's
like tying it all into relationships and
like kind of like what you're saying the
same way we set goals and vision boards
and visualize our futures in like
careers
i mean i think you can agree that my
system is a little more organized
no but and it's more thorough than they
do in the book
well then they stole it from you
i'll see you in court
i mean it's like writing a to-do list i
don't think it's like a patented thing
but would be nice is very important this
is the column
must is absolutely not no matter how hot
they are no matter how sexy they are no
matter how whatever
how much they recreate my childhood
circumstances and they make me feel like
my mom and my dad combine and
recreate it's just like um the answer is
no
would be nice let's get to this it's
important okay would be nice
um if he had if he understood the
industry a little bit
just so this is huge ah
you are so fucking far ahead in this
because
the fact that you know that i didn't
learn until i was 30 literally a year
ago
uh you want because we tend to go i
don't want anyone in my field i don't
want to date anyone in my field but if
they don't know anything about it
they can't empathize with your problems
that sometimes seem like brags
right but it is true that's such a good
point but it is a real problem yeah
yes no absolutely and i feel like that's
time and time again been like a
oh they can't understand any job yeah
any job
when you come home and you complain
about something happy you work today and
they're just like what's the big deal
and you're like
okay i needed someone that had some
sympathy for my
circumstances yeah yeah just a little
understanding that would be nice it goes
a long way
yes yes or and also dare i say a
willingness to learn
absolutely i feel like that's a must you
tell me sure
this is your husband okay willingness
to course correct slash learn i know i
have to get you out of here but we have
to finish this
we can't not we can't let your husband
just he can't just be floating
he's your husband he can't just be on
this earth and we like don't know where
he is he doesn't even know where you are
so we have to connect you to
um let's see wait understood industry
okay that's would be nice what let me
read mine
or give it to her she can read mine oh
it's just funny that she's trying to
chime in you're like wait i know i know
not now lindsay okay no this is really
important i take this shit very
seriously and
like every every woman i know has had to
sit through this with me okay
um and their lives are much better now
likes uh
games not not emotional games
sex sex games wow we're getting a lot
out of lindsay on this path
sorry like board games
that's so much kinkier than a sex game
it's like full who's afraid of virginia
woolf
we're playing scrabble game night like
what games
oh like strategy games i'm such a nerd
like uh like duck duck goose oh no
like um like a board game like like
splendor or
scrabble or
cerebral games yes yes so smart card
games
so this person needs to be cerebral i'm
putting that in must
okay cause you're a smarty pants
game night okay game night uh
brain games i know a lot of guys that
would be like game night awesome what
are we doing and then you're like great
brain games are like
yeah that's why you played poker yes
would be nice we have to be specific
about what kind of games you're playing
because a lot of guys cannot play
scrabble the guy a lot of guys i've
dated
can't make one word shoot um so yes you
need a smarty pants that's good
um let's see can you read my must so now
i can't uh lindsay has my red flag list
okay let's see i'm sorry this is musts
what is it passport
is on the must you got some good ones
here oh no what else from us oh no no
it's good
hygienic you have to get something very
specific like this
you have to tell the universe exactly
what you want you can't be vague
not a what is that not a
i'm curious i'm like has to have good
handwriting what is this
uh does it doesn't go to music festivals
okay incredible
because i just was at this point where
it's like every guy was ever dating
would like go to some music festival for
a week and cheat on me and i was like no
more of music festivals not allowed
you're going to cheat on me it's going
to be with a hooker
in private and no one is going to put on
town yeah in town where i can find you
not in the dust helps me grow
uh self-aware where did not a comedian
that's in my musts i think that's fair
enough by the way how about this how
about this wait this is my favorite part
of my list that i just noticed
on musts the fourth one down is
self-aware
and then about the oh tenth one down is
self-aware that was really important
in case you forgot universe for the
least self-aware person on the planet
fuck
not a narcissist gives good advice
that's
important that's a good one i i gotta be
honest with you i didn't even realize
that like i and
i didn't realize why that was so
important until i just reread it because
when you're in a relationship and you
have lots of big decisions you have to
make which you
really do um and you don't go to your
person
and you go to someone outside the
relationship you're getting emotional
support from someone outside and you
start to build this narrative if the
person doesn't understand me
this person can't you know like like and
if you have a problem
if you don't tell the person you start
investing emotionally in other
people and it just drives a wedge and
it's super fucked up i didn't realize
that until this relationship
very very insightful very wise it's
important yes
yeah okay and it was advice i took see
you have to take it right you have to
take advice
from your person and you have it on the
list there's a great yeah put on the
list and then um
uh the the book committed by elizabeth
gilbert
has a really great i love elizabeth
gilbert is that a good book
yes committed she talks about what
marriage means in every culture
and uh like how it originates and stuff
like that and
she talks about how you have to close
the doors in the windows if you're in a
relationship that's what she calls it
like when you're at work you can't
emotionally invest
in everyone at work are you getting
hungry or tired no
i'm looking at you i'm like worried your
blood sugar is starting to no i've got
my
my fruit infused yeah that will last you
another
five minutes yes i'm good uh but uh uh
uh so you close the doors in windows so
that you don't like like when something
exciting happens at work like in your
work probably so
such long days sometimes when you're
shooting and like something happens and
you like
tell this person you tell this person by
the time you get home to your partner
they're like how's your day and you're
like good what else like you've already
talked about it too many times
or you've you don't feel the need to
emotionally invest it with them so you
don't
and then they just start knowing you
less and less and you start bonding with
the people you're working with more and
more
and then that we have emotional affairs
yes
she's like i've never had this problem
but i guess i'll just
pretend i have yesterday so you feel
better about
your creation no i think that's
something that every well i mean
honestly when i'm on tour
yeah my tour is like my family like at
this point you know i see them much more
as brothers
but i know that when i've dated people
when i'm touring a lot it's really hard
for them to see that there's those
very you know those relationships that
are very much
like we're so close and i think that
it's
important that when a when a guy does
that it's it on some way it's his way of
saying
i can't imagine anyone wouldn't fall in
love with you
because i'm so in love with you i can't
imagine anyone else wouldn't
give anything that's sweet that is a
fairy you have such sweet perspectives
on
so many things thanks yeah you're like
you're like well it's probably because
they just can't imagine i love you dude
the prozac is kicking back in i think
i'm out of mine i need to take it
somewhere oh i have some extra i need it
okay that's
not legal never mind honestly
i'm going to give you some of my prozac
i would love for like a cop to show up
my house and be like i heard you gave
some someone in your office one of your
pros out you're like you wouldn't want
to work with her either if she wasn't on
her pros
officer yeah no also yeah hey officer
don't we have a bigger problem
like i feel like i'm pregnant shit like
that slides
do what i mean with everything that's
going on it's like how they let the
parking violations go
my sister she started this thing that
made me really think
she was like did you realize that so
often whenever i make a little tiny
mistake like you spill the soda you know
it's like you immediately go to
i'm so stupid like i can't believe i did
that of course this would happen to me
right and you build this narrative that
you're the only person that has
inconveniences
the only person that like forgets things
like like no one's ever done that before
and so
she started this habit of like saying
out loud
whoopsie like when she does something
and she's like it's a whoopsie moment
and that way it reminds me that like
that's all it is whoopsie something
and i spilled the coke or i forgot that
or like that's gravity's fault that's
not your fault
that's a gravity thing but there's a i
think for me every little
thing that i did i used to take as an
opportunity to beat myself up absolutely
yeah emotional cutting and it was just
sort of like
i did that i did that it's like you made
the choice
i made the choice to hurt myself just
now stop and think is it the end of the
world
do i have to beat myself up for this no
and do i want to
so why if so why where did i get that
messaging where did i think
when did this work because it's not
working now but it probably did work at
some point when i had to make myself
smaller
to make someone feel whatever like now
it's like it just doesn't work anymore
mm-hmm it doesn't serve me drop it
because it just doesn't serve you
anymore
absolutely if it serves you lock
yourself out okay
would be nice no but it's fascinating to
when you learn a lot about yourself when
you're making this list yeah
the way your brain works the way you go
from bad to good instead of like is
there an in between that i could live
without i'm not like that i'm a very
fucking like
if you're in or you're out yeah you
you're good or you're bad
like and then i'm like oh no there are
things that i that'd be great
but if he doesn't have them that's fine
too yeah my brain doesn't
work in that space very the gray yeah
the gray area is hard um okay
um likes to eat kind of healthy that's a
eat kind of healthy that's good
and then by the way i don't need a
health nut but just like i don't want to
be
in and out every day um
like knows how about music no it's about
materialistic i'm not a materialistic
person
you aren't but what i will say
is that you know when someone has like
material things
like an apartment and a cart that does
mean they
work hard and they save their money and
they're responsible yes as long as
they're not super
materialistic they can have nothing so
finance so okay this is interesting
so you're making me realize a must could
be financially independent and a red
flag could be materialistic
yes i'm saying there's a difference yes
i do not yeah
materialistic bad self-sufficient good
is that fair yes isn't that what we put
on your list twice yeah oh no
that was self-aware i'm sorry which
we'll never know if it was on yours
twice i think we should put it on he
could do that that doesn't mean
you don't have to be any of these things
he just has to be these things your
partner has to be these things exactly
you're allowed to have a double standard
yeah
don't worry shoot for the stars ladies
yeah this person doesn't have to be as
terrible as i am they have to be better
um okay so would be nice uh we still can
add musts you have lots of musts
not a lot of red flags we need more red
flags okay um these are things that
you'd fucking u-turn when you hear about
them or see them
like rude to wait stuff what we're just
giving the um the inmates like a
blueprint of what to write in their next
letter
to lindsay oh my god
red flags also um
i think jealous is a really good one
jealous is a really good one
um uh what about like
talks about girlfriends on a first date
i mean that's not like a hard and fast
rule but like
rude to wait staff is a big one for me
yeah that's a
because here's the other thing this is
great because you'll say something
and then you can talk through it with
someone and realize that it's actually
your problem so
i'll say you know like i don't want this
and then i'll be like no that's just me
being like
uh um what's the word uh judgmental
and a perfectionist and then possibly
like impossibly high expectations for
somebody yeah and if whatever you put on
here you should
also be able to deliver on it
as i'm talking through it i'm like
because it also makes you go well i need
to work on that
yeah yeah i should you know what because
then it's would you date you yeah
exactly
you got to be able to live with yourself
if your soul mate is writing stuff down
would you live up to all their things
you know because we all walk around
assuming we're perfect and
need nothing else you know there's
sometimes where it's like yeah i want
that
yeah you know what i if i want to
attract that i need to be less
shitty in that department ooh
pessimistic yes
so we are never dating i got it i got it
loud and clear girl
loud i hear it when i hear a boundary
pessimistic just like negative overly
negative oh really negative
in the wrong room
um let's see red it's a red flag if they
don't have like a good relationship with
their family
huge we get it we're not dating your red
flags are pulled up in the book
okay because i had a um doesn't talk
shit about
mothers okay red flag day drinking
ego problem oh dear same day plans
gives me adrenaline wait that they make
same-day plans with you mm-hmm
no same-day plans oh it was a boundary
these red flags for your
well there's a no in advice for emily oh
that's what this chapter is
um no it was uh uh when i was in
recovery for love addiction a big thing
that they do in sex and love addiction
is they'll set like a bottom line
of what doesn't work so same day plans a
lot of times is like you end up
if if the person you're into reaches out
at six and you have a dinner plan with
your friend at seven you'll be like
i'll just cancel it i'll do it and then
you end up destroying all your
relationships
and being a flake to drop for this one
person
you know and uh the person you should be
really with should be like hey i'd like
to see you on wednesday you know they
can schedule ahead of time so i tell
if i'm dating it's on sunday you can
make a plan for the week
if you don't you don't see me and if
that you're okay with that then you
don't want to date me i don't like it
now i know
yeah no no same day plans i'm too old to
have that standard
unless you're like unless the person has
already shown that they can show up for
you
and will invest in you and is
responsible right if now
he's like hey do you want to go for a
hike later i'm like of course but like
in the beginning you want to be courted
a little bit
show me that you can put something in
your calendar and
show up when you say you're gonna stick
to a commitment let me just see that
let me just see it like two or three
times and then we can get casual into
what are you doing in an hour
you know what i mean absolutely that's a
good point yes but we're
on social media for work if you're just
scrolling over like lingerie models all
day it's
weird if it's your job and you're on it
all day because it's part of your job
and but when you're just like scrolling
i'm good it uh rude to wait steph
red flags oh yeah tells me to relax
dark i wrote dark web
by the way do you see how it's written
in the side it's like an afterthought
just like well i'm squeezing it
it was like no i do have lives in
another city
because i was dating long distance and i
will
be in a half and half out relationship
to avoid your intimacy
any day of the week so i had to put that
down for myself so are the red flags
non-negotiable nose
yes or are they oh okay if you have any
of these things you do not move forward
with me
okay i do not text you back like we're
done i'm not spending any of my life on
this part it's not
ah so close let's date and we'll get you
to where i need you to be
yeah it's like no no these are just for
me
yeah if you these you can take any back
that you want these are just things that
kept
fucking up my life oh stds
you know if it's treatable by the way
yeah as if they'd ever tell you
so honesty yeah so honestly
honestly about stds i should have done
that one damn it
no wonder you said to be specific by the
way
litter bug oh no litter bug
is littering dude i'm telling you i'm
going on my list i'm telling you
i caught it i will fall out of love with
someone
so fast and i know that psychotic yeah
if i was madly in love with someone
engaged and they like threw a can out
the window of a moving car i'd be like
i'm calling the police on you
and i'm done like i it drives me nuts
when people litter yeah
you know what's so funny is one of the
things that i remember
was like a random red flag that i
wouldn't have thought would have bugged
me so much but like i was on a date with
a guy and you know when there's like
the lane that's running out and you know
it's running out and the
the jerky cars past the line yes
and like everybody else is getting over
they wait to merge till the last second
they cut someone off
well like we were going down this road
and that was happening and i was like
hey
we got to get over like the you know i
didn't know if he knew my area and that
the lane ran out
and he didn't get over and he's like no
no it's like he's like he's not against
the law i'm just getting you know
and literally i never went out there
again i was like i can't handle this
like he has no respect for other
people's time
or or in that moment
here's my thing even if you do like
don't do it on the date with me do it
when i'm not in the car
right to to not go like i'm gonna
pretend i don't do this thing because it
clearly bothers
to not even like yeah pretend it should
be like you can deal with i know you
didn't like it but like deal with it
it's just like dude
like i was like oh this is really
bothering me and if you had yeah like
even if it does the fact that it's
bothering me should kind of just be
enough for you to go okay i'm just not
going to do this right now
right did i mean yeah but i don't know
why that rubbed me wrong
so bad right because it's so fucking
rude it's so real and entitled and i'm
the only person that exists
exactly it's like no one else matters my
time's more important even though we're
not rushing to go anywhere
we've all done it before when you're
like i'm going to miss my flight and
this the only time i really yes i do it
then
but when i have an a sick or very badly
injured animal in the car
right there's there's i'm like and
everyone's like got it no problem
you know but most of the time it just
makes you so mad when other people do it
to you and just show such a disregard
anyways you just fucked up so many
people's day yeah do you know what i
mean
yeah yeah your time's no better than all
the rest of it that's so
that's such a good one so that's a minus
has a car
um okay so rude in traffic
um um but wait we're coming up on three
hours i know but
come on you have to be somewhere let me
see well she's not no i'm good
okay so we canceled the important things
that make her money
got it good good yeah that concert
tonight just tell me i can't make it no
right now we're just building her
presence on youtube because it's very
weak
um uh red flag sorry last ones
uh actions and words are congruous
oh that's very like well stated
red flag in a band
that's so funny secretive
dishonest dismissive oh yeah those are
all
dismissive's hard to see in the
beginning though what you but you saw it
yeah you don't need any of this help and
i'm just giving it to you
no i'm going to go home and one study
this list and then i'm going to make it
i'm going to add to it like i'll make my
real one
add to it i'll throw it away because i
don't need one because i'm making good
decisions and i don't need a guide
no everybody needs it's good to write
down things i'm a big believer it's good
to just
remind yourself like this is a thing
that six months in
i needed i didn't eat at the beginning
when we're all like in the honeymoon
phase and everything was so
like sexy but like this is something
that i realize when i'm with someone all
the time bothers me
and yeah it's not you know what i'm
saying like it's just a thing that's
gonna get me
eventually it's the kind of thing that
right now i can sort of
turn it into being cute like when you're
into someone you'll put up with anything
yeah communication that's everything if
you can just communicate your boundaries
emotionally intelligent you need all
that yeah all that good stuff um
and if i communicate the boundaries then
the sneaky thing is you have to respect
them
i know all right well i would do that
look i want to talk to you forever
and i know i am not allowed to let me
just ask you one more question
uh which is if you or me is there
anything
you would have asked you that i missed
oh i always like in my interviews i'm
like
this thing you know what i have a really
good story for a good account
like are you ever like like because i
mean i i
just imagine i watch interviews with
people and i feel like they get asked
the same thing over and over again and
it's just like i feel
i never want to do that so there's a lot
of questions i'm like don't ask for that
it's been asked or
your fans can find the answer on another
video like i try to like go okay your
fans are like looking at photos or
videos of you probably photos too
um obsessively then they're gonna
stumble on this interview i don't want
them to see the same thing they just saw
you answer in five other videos
absolutely um what questions do you uh
do not want to get what questions do i
not want to get
um honestly i'm usually pretty chill to
talk about most things
i mean my favorite is politics obviously
i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
another
if anyone does have an interview they're
a fucking asshole yeah it's like
to bring any of that up is so shitty
yeah um
no i think i mean we talked about so
many cool things that i usually never
talk about usually don't ever talk about
relationships so this was really fun
i'm obsessed with you we should be
friends i think we should
go hang out don't you think yeah am i
allowed to be her friend
from a brand new standpoint are you sure
this is a good idea
yes let's be friends if i if her youtube
views start going down you let me know
and i will well we're not going to put
you in my music videos
oh
[Music]
maybe go to less therapy uh you're a
little too well adjusted
um no i would absolutely
and i appreciate this list i really am
going to go home and add to it
i'm going to tell you i'm telling i
thought it was stupid when i first
started making it i thought it was
ridiculous i'm like i know what i want
and i am it and i've read all these but
it's when
you get swept away by the guy who's in
thirty thousand dollar debt but is very
handsome
and shaves his chest um
you'll be able to refer back to that and
be like oh yeah no yeah no
he was rude to the waitress no nope nope
and your logical brain just refers to
that
and your visceral reactions don't get to
make your life choices
i love that because if my heart
could choose i'd be with the
married man in uh okay yeah i'd say i'd
be with some married guy in
guatemala okay so thank god for this
list
um lindsay before we go will you tell us
about your new single oh yes
please well that's what i was supposed
to say when you ask if there's anything
else i want to talk about he's been
sitting here for three hours like at
some point can we get a
um okay so just go for it and talk yeah
tell us i want to hear from you i love
you
now that you're at you're most tired uh
and have low blood sugar dehydrated now
talk about the important thing
well um i really am super excited we
just released a new song it's called
lose you now and
this one is like i know we artists say
that like every release is super special
and we're always like well this one's
really
important but this song really is just
there's something magical about it as
i'll say
you're not a uh one of those artists
that everyone thinks
like is like in a press junket saying
what a publicist made them say
right i believe everything you say well
thank you you're welcome um
yeah and this this song is about like
loss it's about my experience and losing
my best friend and my dad they both
passed away
to cancer within a year of each other
and you know this song
i feel like i was finally in a place to
write about it in
not such a dark way you know like there
is a very beautiful optimistic feel to
this song so for anybody that's lost
anything whether it's like you know lost
love through
the diverse ways that we can all lose
love um this is a song about hope and
about that how everything we go through
we get to carry pieces of it with us
and i personally believe that my dad and
my best friend are like my guardian
angels now
and that they guide me all the time and
i like i consider them walking around me
as i go through my every day and it
actually gives me a lot of comfort and
strength and
so that's what this song is about about
taking the pieces of your past that you
want
and keeping them with you regardless of
how you lost them i love this so much
wow yeah um yeah is anyone dealing with
loss right now
i mean what a perfect song for
everything everybody is going through
and in terms of the lost thing
i'm sorry i know i'm going to let you go
but that is such a big deal because i
think that
when you i lost my dad a couple years
ago and like you really
there's no one you can only talk to
other people that lost their dads it's
this weird thing where like
you know even your closest friend
doesn't get you know what i mean it's
and then
and then there's this um sort of
additional uh pain that is when you're
grieving everyone else feels awkward and
they feel like they can't help you and
then you feel i feel like i'm creating
stress for them because i'm so sad and
you know what i mean it's like when
someone you love
uh someone close to them dies like you
feel helpless and you can't
you know what i mean like and i guess i
just realized at the time like it
that kind of grief transcends
conversation
absolutely it just has to be music it
has to be
well and it was interesting i first
wrote this song as an instrumental
because i couldn't even find the words
to say to express how i felt and then
you know i worked with another artist
who actually wrote the lyrics for it um
and i was so excited because he was able
to put into words what i was never able
to
to say and you know you're right though
it transcends conversation in another
way like i used to always think i didn't
know what to say
to someone if they lost someone like i
just didn't have the words there's
nothing to say
but like you mentioned like i feel like
i'm sadly part of the dead dad's club
you know and or anytime you lose anyone
you realize you don't actually have to
say anything there's like an empathy
that can be felt whether it's through
music or whether it's through a hug or
whether it's just through like
you know like that feeling that you
share with someone of like
i understand um and so and even if you
don't understand
like that's okay okay you don't have to
pretend you understand by saying your
cat
is sick sheryl sandberg wrote that book
about um
grieving when her husband suddenly died
and yes i read it
it's option b uh is that what it is plan
b
yeah no that's the pill i took this
morning um yeah something like that
and and um she said that when her
husband died she went to work and no one
would talk to her
right it's so true people either go like
i get it
you're either smothered or you're
avoided and that's a really hard place
to sit between
yes and so i i mean for anyone that
knows anybody that's struggling which
you will at some point if you don't know
anyone who's lost someone
i mean i think just being this like this
presence of like
whatever you need to be whenever you
need to be it i'm here for you yes
you know and even through my breakup
recently like i mean that's obviously
not a loss or a death but it's
no i killed him he's dead we won't talk
about
that because this is on record right
yes but i had some friends that reached
out and they were like
what do you need like do you need us to
come be with you do you want to be alone
like we are here for it regardless and
like you know just
people like that whether you know we
just need to let people know that you
can be whatever you need to be and i'm
here for it
and like and that is like genius like if
someone's going too bad
do you want to talk about it do you not
want to talk like exactly give me
options do you want me to come over
and not bring it up at all yeah did you
want to talk about it for four hours or
do you know what i mean like what do you
need today
asking someone what they need is a huge
thing because you know
thinking that you know the answer even
if you've dealt with exactly what
they're dealing with you think you know
everything
you don't know how they need to deal
with it you don't know what day they're
on of grief like
you know yes and something that uh
she said in her book cheryl stamberg and
i know there was a co-author that i'm
forgetting
um but uh some guy uh
sheryl sandberg and some guy who was it
written by um sheryl sandberg and that
dude
um uh that if you don't know what to do
drop something off at their house drop
something off
or if it's someone's in the hospital you
go wait in the fucking
lobby and you on downstairs if you want
to talk if not i'll be here till four
reading a book
i'm fine don't need to see it but if you
wanna you know what i mean i'm here
or i drop you know drop something off
their house without needing credit
that's the other thing is i even find
myself doing it when someone's going
through something bad i'm like
do you mean do this and this and this
it's like am i wanting credit
or am i for being there or am i just
uncomfortable with this person's pain
that i feel the need to
make myself give give them homework for
me like when someone now says like
what can i do i'm like well you're
giving me homework now
for you i always say um like
you don't have to respond to this i hope
yes that's great so good
because then it's so good you don't have
to i'm not expecting it don't
because i always feel an obligation to
respond so if i say that right off the
bat then i'm just like
take it and go right that's good that's
that's a great
way because sometimes when we try to
take care of people we make them take
care of us by accident and we don't even
know we're doing it
when someone tries to help and they just
create more work for you and you're just
like i just i don't think you see this
but i see it myself doing it sometimes
yeah and i have to catch myself
right giving the options giving the
option not to respond at all
you know because i think there's a lot
of power in just showing up like a lot
of times people just
they we all just want to know that
people are aware and they haven't
forgotten and they're not afraid of us
they're not afraid to talk to us it's
like just
by showing up whether it's leaving
something or just saying hi or like
making you feel like it's okay to be
wherever you're at the grief
conversation is like
losing someone this young i just think
no one prepares you for that
because in our heads we're like our dads
die when we're in our like 50s or
you know what i mean like and then it
happens to you and you're just like no
no
you know been there absolutely yeah
i'm so sorry i didn't know you'd had
that experience as well my
life is harder than yours and i need you
to help and take care of me emotionally
i know i just made this about my dead
dad but i'm just i'm like it's related
no it's relating for sure
it's there there's an understanding that
comes from that absolutely
yeah just like and then um yeah and i
just feel like with everything that's
going on in the amount of
crossing over we have going on just in
our news and in our life like it's just
like
a song like this at a time like this to
like stay focused on hope and not all
the negativity that we're seeing all day
every day
even if it's not going on in our own
nuclear families it's just
yeah no it's she's the best it's
definitely a time for some hope and
upliftment and i'm here for it that's
your fault
that's my thing you're like a um
like who are the princesses and that
come in and make everything better
like who's an enchanted like a princess
a disney princess yeah but like you're
like does the sparrow help you get
dressed in the morning
do chipmunks help you clean your clothes
in the yard and i speak to animals
exactly yes i feel like i speak to them
they do not speak back i feel like they
speak back to you
oh no they don't speak back but i just
i'm just saying that i just feel like
yeah they like comb your hair and though
like she has like birds and like frogs
and squirrels like doing all her makeup
and hair
oh you are too guy so my makeup looks
like it was
done by a frog yeah
a sloth something with three fingers
seem to have done your makeup
i mean i look like an actual cracker so
no i would never
i would never um okay i love you
um uh lindseystarling.com
uh you guys already know this but it is
l-i-n-d-s-e-y
yes which i get wrong a lot yeah so a
lot of people
lots of people and then the last name is
the tricky one too s-t-i-r-l-i-n-g
that is two weird spellings in a row
yeah
my name is usually spelled both first
and last wrong
not wrong you could have 24 million
how many follows have you missed out on
because
i'm just i'm not saying change the name
of the spelling there's a lindsay
sterling out there that's spelled the
other way that is just getting all kinds
of oh yeah
all kinds of attention and she played
the show she learned how to play violin
she like shows up to the blog all the
time
oh fuck you brought in with the wrong
spelling the other one's
more famous strictly because
searchability it's fine
yes lindsey sterling l-i-n-d-s-e-y
s-t-i-r-l-i-n-g
dot c-o-m-m no
just a throat just as to keep the trend
going no dot com
um if you do something at dot c-o-m-m
i'm sure would still go to dot com no
i don't think so let's just not try to
make it harder
there's not like a re-route um
unreal i love you i know i have to let
you go i end these very awkwardly
um don't ride elephants uh and i love
you and i'm very excited
listen to lindsay's new single oh yeah
listen to the new singer no i want to
play if i play right now will i get uh
sued no no i'll then email her later and
be like you have to fix this you have to
un-sue me please the licensing stuff's a
bitch
pickle yeah i know musicians come on the
show and they're like no don't play my
music no no
no no no no do not do that do not you
don't want that to happen and i'm like
what's the problem and they're like
please turn that
road off they're really like we need you
to turn it off like truly right now like
there was three bars and now you need to
stop
um or else you're gonna get a bill for
50 grand
um oh and then i have an idea you said
something earlier um
about uh you were like i was just
playing a random concerto
is that you pronounce it oh yes concerto
concerto i was just like concerto
you should do i think she needs career
advice for me let's be honest
i'm just here to help uh an album where
you
do concertos and it's just called random
concertos random concertos
i like it that's what you call them and
that was so funny if you just had an
album
like you could do a concerto album right
right
is that covers though yeah i guess they
would be covers
yeah do all this to not have to do that
why are you
trying to make me go backwards re-pitch
no those would be when you know you
should do open mics again
all right we're just you're just going
backwards is it is that
is that a backwards thing open mic
nights no no i know
me uh uh uh cover another contra i just
i know
literally nothing you know what they're
so difficult like so it would actually
be
like i'm practicing a lot you know covid
because i have time right now so i'm
actually practicing a lot and i'm going
back to like relearn some of these old
concertos
because i mean the music that i play now
that i you know tour and stuff
i mean it's it's difficult in its own
way but like it's nothing compared to
like a classical
like boil your fingers to death concerto
so
wow so like not a step backwards i
wouldn't i just mean like in terms of i
have no idea because i never
in some businesses like you don't know
you know but it's like i mean in terms
of creatively like is that
is like like once you do this you can't
go back to you it's like once you are a
movie star you're not allowed to host
talk shows
you know what i mean there's all these
weird little things
i mean yeah once you've like released
your own original music you like don't
want to ever be known as a cover
artist again but i mean i'll
occasionally cover something if i feel
like it
like wow this movie score is really cool
like
i'll cover it you know so i don't i
don't hold any hard fast lines but
you know do you feel weird when people
cover yours i get so excited really
oh my gosh
no one time i was walking through
seattle and i was down at
pike's place um i'm walking through and
i hear
someone playing one of my songs and
there's this kid on the corner playing
the violin
rocking out one of my songs and it was
one of the sweetest moments of my life
i like turned the corner and popped in
front of him you know
like while filming and i was like you're
doing great and
you know his fit it was like the
sweetest moment ever so
yeah whenever i hear someone playing my
music where's that video
um i can find it you cannot you don't
have to get i'm just saying we have to
it's on my instagram we'll send you a
link to it because his face is just
priceless and he didn't the best part is
he didn't stop playing
lindsay and then he just like started
playing his little heart out and it was
the best moment
like the best thing ever so cute how old
was this person
he was probably like i'm gonna say like
20. he wasn't like a child he was like
what are the chances that you're
playing in fucking seattle yeah
and she walks by right like crazy
it was a yeah it was a cool moment for
both of us that's like
so it's almost cruel if you weren't so
delightful
because it almost like
like i would like be very like scared
i'm sure it was of like no yeah it would
be like it's just like one of those
things it's like
so creepy that you're like oh my god
like
you know what universe is trying to do
yeah when you run into someone that you
were just thinking about and you're like
oh my god i'm a witch i'm manifested oh
my god i'm a witch i don't know
you're like i can't be trusted to go
anywhere anymore like you start to be
like i'm just too powerful
i can't think anything i'm drunk on my
own power okay yeah if i think of
something it's going to come true
but then it's like if by that logic the
pandemic was your fault asshole
like when i'm like i manifest too hard
don't look at me don't look at me
if i fall in love with you you'll have
to marry me like when you start thinking
your mind is like too powerful
yeah it happens it's the slippery slope
um i'm in love with you i cannot wait to
hang out with you and make you come back
on the show your manager won't let you
but i'm gonna text you manipulate you
and she'll be back folks all right even
against them because you're manifesting
it
right now if i manifest it's gonna
happen bitches
and you and and now it's time for me to
give you my
sweatshirt oh yeah i get the sweatshirt
yeah
it's got sweat stains on it
it's like the secretly meanest gift ever
like
you better smell could you smell it
doesn't smell
i actually didn't drink oh you know what
it's not that bad actually because i
i did use the ball wipes i did use those
those manscape ball likes on my um
armpits they work folks yeah that's not
so bad
some wipes no we can set you up with
some
some ball wipes yes you've come to the
right place
we have a whole closet full of them well
thank you thank you for having me
this is so delightful thank you for
doing this um your manager's like
i have some cuts um your dream and i
feel like people will be so excited to
see
you for three hours straight you're
welcome okay when you watch on talk
shows you get 10 minutes
five minutes 15 minutes i gave you
motherfuckers three hours so
boom you're welcome and she wanted she's
wanted to leave for the past half hour
and i made her stay that's i have not
that's
how devoted to my fans i am
and i don't have 12 million viewers so
my channel actually has more content of
her than her channel
at this point so by this logic
i should have the same number of
subscribers by next week
can't wait all right you heard it there
first
[Applause]
[Music]
you